[Music]
[Applause]
welcome the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith we are here at the scum and
villainy Cantina in Hollywood California
right on Hollywood Boulevard
put your hands ago this is the folks
watching at home know that you were real
so much real very real normally I love
and celebrate the fact that this can't
the cantina is on Hollywood Boulevard in
Hollywood California such a wonderful
thing right but tonight of all [ __ ]
nights we normally try to start this
show well it's it's slated to start at
8:00 usually starts at 8:30 tonight
we're starting at [ __ ] 9:00 and that
you'd normally I'm to blame because I'm
like I'm getting high in the back alley
but not tonight well I did but after
[ __ ] sitting in traffic for one
[ __ ] hour to get here because the
goddamn Hollywood Bowl man I hate to be
first-world but [ __ ] Los Angeles culture
oh my god it was unbelievable I sat in
New York like traffic and I'm like I'm
not getting New York payoffs for this
man
it was tough so sorry for starting late
it was just a bunch of [ __ ] traffic
and stuff that being said thank you so
much mary j blige did not carjack you on
your way over is that whose response
mary j blige and NAS let me - oh my god
they are so [ __ ] popular cuz I've
honestly never seen traffic patterns
this bad and I've seen all sorts of
[ __ ] bull traffic and I live around
the block from the Hollywood Bowl thank
Christ
Mark texted before I left the house bull
traffic because otherwise the way I go I
would I wouldn't have gotten here I
would have been getting here like right
now and it would be like cancel this
[ __ ] show there is no
but thankfully I went the long way
around and still it took a minute to get
here and set up the fat signal do
troubled by the well the fat signal it's
a little hanging fruit but I loved it it
was perfect look us two years to get
there
somebody did that to me I was talking to
we were shooting spots for Jay and
Silent Bob reboots coming out and we've
got it thank you
and we've got the tour that we're gonna
be doing for like six months and [ __ ]
what we had a Taurus Ponce I don't know
if we've announced it yet so I'll keep
it quiet but we shot some spots and
wraparound spots for the tour sponsor
that will play on the tour and also go
into our social media and stuff and the
folks that we shot the spots with were
from Jersey as well though like hey man
the thrill because I'm also am a Jersey
boy I'm like oh [ __ ] where are you from
and they were like down South Jersey and
stuff I know you're Central Jersey
we're down and I've never heard this
expression and you're from my neck of
the woods ich ich and we've got
connections I do mind you married into
my neck of the woods and I know that's
better judgment this expression I've
never heard South Jersey borders Phillip
Philadelphia and Pennsylvania Jersey
Delphia
I've never [ __ ] heard that 49 years
of my life so this guy said I'm from the
Jersey Delphia area and I was like I'm
[ __ ] stealing that and I'll try to
give you credit if I remember but [ __ ]
that's good man have you ever heard
Jersey Delphia I've never heard that
before but that sounds like a dude who
doesn't want to be from South Jersey the
word that's not quite so good to state
area true it'd be like I'm from Jersey
York and they're like that's not a thing
man no all right so wait why did I tell
that [ __ ] story on good point but I
do know a [ __ ] story that's on brand
for the show oh and I couldn't wait to
do something happened this weekend and
what happened I was like oh man I wish
we were doing Fatman beyond this week
and then somebody was like you are
and I was like oh holy [ __ ] I've got
great opening material a [ __ ] life
then I forgot because I was in traffic
and I was so mad but now I'm back here
and I remember I went to an event for an
organization wonderful organization 20
years old called Mercy for Animals if
they're an organization obviously it's
right there on the title they don't bury
the lead guess how they feel about
animals Marc they're very Pro animal and
stop no mercy for animals yeah that's
it's a different organization altogether
the turkey leg Johnny sweep the turkey
leg that was [ __ ] brilliant man
the Mercy for Animals folks had a gala
or a gala and I say properly my kid they
put me and my kid on the cover of their
magazine a few months ago they're like
will you come to the gala gala
absolutely so we we went as a family me
and my wife my kid went as well so when
you get there you know like I felt like
like I knew one of the reasons why my
kid I had the heart attack and my kid
was like go vegan dad
hey I know she wanted to save my life B
I knew she knew that I would be a big
get for the vegan community you know
like if we can flip him holy [ __ ] he'll
help us legitimize this nonsense you
know so she you know part of it was
personal part of it I think was not
political but just like I've got an
agenda here one of us on what exactly so
you know it was her world that she
brought me into and stuff and in that
world
she's already established as like a man
she's vegan his [ __ ] and vegan
princess low vegan princess and [ __ ]
don't call her that but yes that's kind
of what she is so she was like the big
deal in the room but I also felt like
alright well you know of course they're
bringing me cuz [ __ ] like I might be
the world's most famous vegan and [ __ ]
like that or whatever forgetting people
like Moby and [ __ ] like that
forgetting like blah like for Edith
pouch for Zika yeah like a lot of people
have been doing Beyonce and jay-z also
famous Vegas but I felt like going in
there I'm like oh my god like other than
the kid I'll be like probably the most
[ __ ] famous person here that never
happens unless I go to like a high
school reunion so this is gonna be
[ __ ] amazing
I walked in there like you're gonna be
sitting with Joaquin Phoenix and he was
at our [ __ ] table man
so was Moby as well but like you know
with with all due respect like you know
I knew he was a vegan I was shocked that
Joaquin was a vegan but then I was
[ __ ] also like I got a lot to talk to
you about so he was that we got to the
table and when we sat down like we made
eye contact and he was like hey and I
pretended that I didn't know he was
gonna be at the table it's like holy
[ __ ] and my wife later on she goes you
were a better actor that people give you
credit for so I said to him one point
he's across stabilising I want to talk
to you man at one point he's like
totally and so later on for like an hour
went behind [ __ ] it was a long event it
was very very cool that was a long event
so at one point we were an hour into it
and the meal hadn't started really it
was more people to know the meal had
started the awards ceremony party I got
you gonna let me guess [ __ ]
the meal was powered it was plant
powered man beyond meat was one of the
sponsors so we got a beyond meat burger
and I mean I eat beyond burgers I'll go
for it so it was awesome [ __ ] you
it was so during the meal like you know
everyone's eaten and she'll like that
and we were both done eating and at one
point a conversational low he fell into
I could see and I was I wouldn't even
talking to my wife there was no
conversation overall well we've been
married 20 what years why would I talk
to her there and so I was just watching
the Joker whole time waiting for my
moment and [ __ ] like that so finally he
was done talking and he looked at me and
I looked at him and I went like this and
then I was saying like you and me man
two minutes give me two minutes and so
he goes he looks at me all weird and
he's like all right wait wait
and then later on he tasked me he's like
let's go and he goes but what do you
want to do because pointing at me and
going like this could mean a lot of
[ __ ] things
I'd blow you up about the [ __ ] movie
and stuff he's like I Elizabeth go
outside so we went outside and I got to
blow him up and stuff about the movie
and I said that [ __ ] movie I was like
this movie's gotta [ __ ] change
everything math I saw somebody online so
there was before Joker and there's after
Joker like [ __ ] I said this is
amazing and he's like have you seen it
it's like [ __ ] no I just saw the trailer
man and he goes well don't you think you
should wait to see the movie I said I
will see the movie come on you come on
this movie looks [ __ ] amazing man
looks awesome and [ __ ] and so I said
look I said I'm not like I'm personally
invested as I love carrying comic book
characters at ship but like anyone who
was [ __ ] famous before like I got
into the business is super [ __ ]
famous to me like I've met many famous
people but some of them like came up
with me like I flick and Ben and Matt
like they're famous but like I also knew
him when they weren't famous and [ __ ]
but there are people in this business
who you meet who are like they were I
was seeing them in movies long before I
even dreamed of making a [ __ ] movie
so I told him I was like look man I just
think you're having this big moment I
think everybody in the world knows you
probably won a boatload awards that [ __ ]
he's like don't say that I was like but
I'm deeply invested not just because I
love comics but like I was a huge
Parenthood fan man
and he looks at me with the widest
[ __ ] eyes and I was like yes that's
how deep I go and [ __ ]
so I'm invested man I'm deeply invested
in your career plus I was like to die
for was a movie that I've watched 500
times it was our go to sleep movie me
and my wife when we first met and [ __ ]
like that and he's in the movie and he's
[ __ ] and brilliant like that's the
first performance where I was I was like
Jesus Christ this guy he and even acted
he's real and I pointed out I was like
you called her he mispronounces her name
the whole [ __ ] movies Nicole Kidman
is his co-star and it's kind of the
story about you know the kids who kill
her husband he's having an affair with
the wife he's a teacher right yeah it's
like the Pamela smart ish story Mary Kay
Letourneau ish I guess something like
that but this one was like somebody
actually died and stuff but it was made
by Gus Vaughn son and you know written
by buck Henry brilliant [ __ ] movie
bit satirical lots teracle and stuff
dark humor but he's in it as the kid who
she has an affair with and her name I
forget as Maggie and arrow or something
and he always mispronounce he's like
Miss Maggie Montano and I said to him I
was like bro when you [ __ ]
mispronounce her name in to die foreign
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was brilliant and he goes
did hi and then I realized I had crossed
from professional into fanboy country
where I was no longer like we are in the
movie business I'm like you're in the
movie business and I've seen a lot of
them man remember that time you were in
that movie and you mispronounce this
lady's name wrong that was amazing
I Chris Farley the [ __ ] out of my man
but it was really sweet so I talked to
him about the flick I was like how was
it man it looks like you went real
easygoing I was very committed he's gone
but he's gone it was the most fun I ever
had making a movie and I was like well
the trailer certainly tells the darker
stories like I know that's what's funny
about it he's gone but I had a best time
as like how's Todd he's gonna [ __ ]
love Todd he said Todd was funny and
clever he said Todd's incredibly
inventive just comes up with stuff on
the spot he had a blast and she'll like
that so we both shared it for a while
and you know he's very modest of course
you know he'd like this made me laugh I
was he was like um you know I like doing
the small movies where I could just like
do my thing and
stuff and I was like well then why did
you do the jokerman like you knew people
are gonna see that he was like I
honestly didn't know if people would go
to this and I was like well guess what
oh [ __ ] world's gonna see this movie
now oh my god I can't [ __ ] wait nice
guy man really sweet dude such a like
actor actor like really committed to the
[ __ ] what was it just blowing away
Meryl that's right man [ __ ] sign
signs and he was that was like my
favorite part of science he was so
committee member at one point that cut
to him and he's in the closet with the
tinfoil hat that wasn't in the script
he's just in the closet right now I did
I got real with him though I told him
man because he did it I guess that's Ron
oh he did some interview or maybe at the
screening where he talked about his
brother River Phoenix where it was like
you know he encouraged me when I was a
young actor in Beauvoir and I told him I
was like I saw that thing you said about
your brother and I was like again like
your brother was famous when I was a kid
man like and and so I was invested in
your old [ __ ] family like just by
virtue of the fact like this one's
related to this one and they're all
talented and they're on the movies and
you know he's been gone for a while so
when you invoked him that like that was
really special for me and he must have
thought I was psychotic like [ __ ]
what are you talking about but that's
how I roll with this [ __ ] it's like real
obviously personal to me so that was
[ __ ] thrilling and stuff but then
like I went up on stage and we had to
present me and the kid were presenting
to a woman who is an investigator
somebody who went undercover in like a
slaughterhouse and found like all these
like violations and they got the law
just meet in here yes well worse than
that but like [ __ ] really change
things where they changed laws where
they got ready to let cages in a lot of
these cases and stuff like that
compassion they've had a compassion now
so they were given her an award because
like you know [ __ ] you don't get paid
for that sort of thing like that was and
if you're an animal lover going
undercover at a [ __ ] slaughterhouse
that's just like ah but somebody's got
to do that work she did it the laws
changed good things so we're presenting
an award to her and I get up with the
kid and I I said before we present the
award I just wanted to say like you know
I almost died from a heart attack [ __ ]
in the whole audience it's like we
[ __ ] know
and so I was like my kid here you know
she was the one that suggested I go
vegan and stuff and that was like a year
and a half ago and it really worked out
and blah blah blah but I was saying like
you know every once in a while when I'm
on social media then I talk about being
vegan or going to in a vegan event or
something like that
like I get people pounce on me like some
cats not everybody but there's a good
portion of cats who are just like [ __ ]
you vegan now meeting four times as much
meat you know and I'm like I don't know
how that math works out but like good
luck to you some people get very
triggered when you're like hey I'm vegan
because I guess maybe their experience
with vegans in the world is that they're
like I'm vegan I'm better than you I'm
the other guy I'm like look I'm vegan
cuz I had to save my [ __ ] life and
you asked me why I lost weight so I'm
telling you and that's vegans and the
answer and I'm sorry so when I put up
posts I have to put up a trigger warning
where I'm like you know warning this is
not to [ __ ] judge you or say that you
got to become vegan this is me simply
talking about my life and [ __ ] like that
I was like so you know I'm used to
dealing with some cats who like cite me
is some sort of snowflake because like
I've become vegan and even though I
became vegan saved my life whatever the
[ __ ] so I said but here tonight I was
like Rob Zombie who also is vegan who
[ __ ] knew Rob Zombie just presented
an award to Kat Von D and I'm sitting at
the table with the [ __ ] Joker being
vegans medalist [ __ ] man and then I
never saw Joaquin after that again
I think you might have [ __ ] bolted
like oh man he called me the Joker but
it was sweet man that he was lovely and
and boy oh boy it was nice to meet a guy
a minute before you know he's gonna be
celebrated for the rest of the fall
right up until awards season and stuff
and at least talked about that
performance whether people liked the
movie or not and it seems like everybody
[ __ ] loves the movie they're gonna
talk about that performance that's all
everybody talks about at this point so
it's nice to sit there with a guy who's
responsible for the performance is he
gonna show you the movie no he asked me
though he's like haven't you seen it yet
I was like who the [ __ ] do you think I
am man Kevin James no I'm Kevin Smith
they don't show me [ __ ] so I'll see it
eventually but no he didn't offer now
that I think about man you just ruined
it cuz I'm like you're right it should
have ended with him gonna want to come
watch it at my house in which me best
friends let's eat vegan snacks yeah
we're both vegan that's right we got one
for you too Tommy what did you do what
did you have as your way I did not talk
to the Joker at all this week because I
don't roll that way
it's been it's been a nose down on
deadlines kind of week he be workin
workin I'm - working working I had a
script for some person who kept on
saying you need to turn in your [ __ ]
script wait where's your revision most
[ __ ] Netflix wants it now oh you
working for Netflix - yeah it's a whole
[ __ ] thing marca turned in his kursi
turned in his Mattel giraffe there's in
the Moto process I should put this out
here me and Mark are working on a show
called Masters of the Universe for the
good folks
[Applause]
the good folks over at Netflix are
making it and we're making it with our
Mattel television our bosses and stuff
so mark turned in his Mattel Draft and
then mark also turned in his Netflix
draft and hands down I mean this is not
to lower anybody else in the process of
elevating but shortest notes from
Netflix were on your draft awesome yeah
that was pretty good and it's not to say
like others had long notes and thus
their scripts were better I had a bunch
of [ __ ] notes on my script and I know
mush it was brilliant
so but you know like [ __ ] Teddy our
exec is deeply invested because he loves
these characters and it's been fun
having him as the boss because you can't
[ __ ] misstep like he's the guy where
he's like ooh this scene had these three
characters man and you're like [ __ ]
hey like he just he knows mo to in and
out and stuff so you getting the
shortest round of notes I thought was a
high compliment to you know it's it's I
mean that's very nice to hear it is
always a [ __ ] blow to the ego that
there are notes at all because you're
always like oh no it's brilliant like I
slaved over this it's great you should
just not call me and tell me how much
you want to kiss me because this draft
was amazing and it's like what's this
page and notes [ __ ] you're supposed
to love it I made it for you
why don't you love the things that I
give you anymore it listened to us it's
so hard right because there is that
instinctive like what do you mean
there's a note like I think this is done
but you're never [ __ ] done don't like
this yeah like what did I do wrong and
to be fair to Netflix's notes when they
give them to you always begin with a
mini paragraph that is incredibly
positive
yeah I've seen all the notes that
they've done for every episode and stuff
so each time it's just like this is
great you guys are on the right track I
can't wait to watch this and it honestly
makes the next few things if they're you
know corrections ways easier to take
you're like huh night so this doesn't
feel like you [ __ ] up like it feels
like hey what you did was cool you know
what would make it cooler this except
the problem
is at some point you realize that that's
a lie and what way because they're
telling you that I mean they they are
trained in the same way that writers are
trained through an executive resident oh
and you don't want to take it you say I
will take a look at that they know
you're not gonna because we're all
adults here we have to say the thing we
need to say to move on to the next topic
all right so they know they have to
butter us just a little bit at the
beginning to then just slide all this
awfulness right up our [ __ ] asses that
they don't like at the end it's like no
man you did a really great job with all
the spelling in this let me tell you
what you [ __ ] up with all that way
let's find the one compliment if the
it's like that oh no it's really well
lit man the sound on that movie was
extraordinary that's what I always do
with my flicks when people like their
[ __ ] sucks I'm like yeah but it wasn't
focus right but now it was a it's not
it's never a good process but of the
processes that I've been through this
was among the least painful yeah I mean
but it's the least painful were deep in
it now - I know it's a mark turned in
his draft Tim turned in his draft Eric
turned in his draft and Diaz draft was
turned in after mine so like we're well
deep into it now the process kind of
starts again it's exciting man and again
it's like working for people that like
what you're doing it's like Mattel or
you know they're very tied to the to the
character in the world because when
we're done they're like we got [ __ ]
keep selling toys from now until the end
of time and stuff so they're happy with
what's going on Netflix seems happy with
what's going on I keep waiting for the
other shoe to drop
you know we're suddenly people like now
I [ __ ] you and it goes away or something
but so far so good man
but that week was I needed to I did
turning this good for you and then
revised my episode of korra Navarro for
season two because that's how deep we
are already into that Wow yeah
so now season one you you didn't work on
but it's up and everyone can see what
one consensus seemed to be on the show
the consensus seems to be if I was going
by rotten tomatoes the audience grade is
like 89 percent and the critics grade is
like 53 percent and to a certain degree
who gives a [ __ ] because you're making
stuff for the audience you're making
things for people who will watch it
whether they enjoy it or not you're
never really making things for critics
right I say as having been a critic
I am never the target audience of the
thing that you're trying to make right
because I know too much
I've thought too much about this [ __ ]
you've heard me I analyze this stuff to
a degree that's probably unhealthy so
I'm gonna have a conversation with you
about it but apparently you're very
aware somebody needed to sit me down and
say like just relax a bit but my brain
just doesn't work that way and that's
that is my own [ __ ] problem that I'm
dealing with with the help of my priests
and my therapist but like you make a
thing for the audience it's gonna watch
it you know and the people that I've
spoken to anecdotally all like I saw the
trailer and that is very much my [ __ ]
and then they watch it they said oh that
was very much my [ __ ] thank you for that
and so Amazon is thrilled with that
because again there are 300 critics in
the world and 300 billion [ __ ] people
and so they're much rather pleased the
300 billion people so what is it like
then to go to work for a show that's up
and running like I guess it's better
than coming in on like we got to build
this thing from the ground up but you
know the rules but see there's so much
fun in the building from the ground up
though true you know there's that like
when you're sitting in a room with like
six other people and you're like what
could this be it's true and I guess we
did kind of do that a little bit with
MOTU I don't think about it because I'm
like well it all existed and we it's
like those toys existed and we were like
bring him to my house this time I'm in
charge and then we [ __ ] did that but
we did actually have to come up with
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I mean Castle Rock
when that was fun the castle rock and
shred well not even show him these
Treadstone was like I know there's a
bunch of boring books we can't mention
that [ __ ] name
but there's at least content that exists
there's a world which [ __ ] would
that be Matt Damon didn't they didn't
they mention didn't you say like the
first trailer they're like kind of born
world we know it in the room like why
can't we say his name well because
there's a bunch of contractions she said
you know when they make the [ __ ]
marketing material it's gonna be from
the Jason Bourne universe and lo and
behold that's exactly what they did
do you like Jason Bourne of the Bourne
movies born again here we go Treadstone
guys why we can't miss this [ __ ] name
in the show it's on the posters now
where I keep it a secret they're selling
it based on yeah but Castle Rock was
very much the what are we doing like
what could this be
is this good what's this town like and
we went down like cul-de-sac so we would
never visit in the show just cuz that we
needed to define the boundaries of what
that world was gonna be right but for a
carnival row there was there's a first
season like we know what it looks like
we know what the cast is we know what
the world feels like we know the
textures of it and all of that stuff and
now we just need to push it someplace
else different and so the process was
shorter because you don't have to invent
that stuff out of whole cloth but it was
a little less rewarding in a way of just
oh now they did that work like they
found the new land and they already
populated it and yeah we get to visit
and that's cool but I as an explorer as
a dramatic explorer the fun is here's a
place nobody's ever been before what
does it look like hmm I'm the other guy
I'm like let's work smarter not harder
if somebody's done this work for us
let's just do it again you know but uh
but yeah my week was not spent hanging
out with jokers and vegans they were
spent drilling down on revisions for
things that I loved but there was no
beyond me there was no vegan wine is
they're vegan wine I think it's all
vegan I mean I
I made a great fruit of the vine you
know it's not like I'm but last time I
checked they don't make wine from like
animal liver or something like that
generally comes out of grapes they do
somebody's like oh no you could get that
beef wine they should beef wine yeah
that's been my week man all right what
I'll show ya and we've got some upfront
stuff to do so wait we talked about that
Ryan are you here hey man it's Ryan come
up to the guest spot I got to see Ryan
this week as I recorded a thing with koi
we'll talk about in a minute it's right
over there
but Ryan Leibowitz for those watching at
home who don't live in the L air you can
hear a [ __ ] whoo and lot of
recognition in the room if you don't
know if you're not wooing at home going
you were more like whoo there is a comic
book store that has existed in this town
going way the [ __ ] far back to the 80s
am I correct 1979
[ __ ] 79 and it's called the Golden
Apple put your hands together
[Applause]
now the applause goes to my dad of
course my old man bill it's a great film
Leibovitz I'm Way too young to have had
a store for 40 years yes Ryan five years
old Kevin Ryan didn't begin at at age
five but Ryan has assumed at the family
business created by mom and dad as well
bill Leibovitz his dad I remember this
like like I was saying before man
anybody who's [ __ ] famous before I
got in the business is [ __ ] famous
for life in 1989 when Tim Burton's
Batman came out we don't have the
internet so you can't deep dive and
watch tons of clips or the trailer over
and over again if you want to see the
trailer you were probably going to a
movie theater or if you were clever
enough to record it off TV Entertainment
Tonight which was the you know if you
loved movies it was the internet before
the Internet in terms of this corner of
the Internet where we talk about pop
culture and movies and TV and [ __ ] they
ran a piece where they put up the you
know trail bits of the trailer and they
talked about how Batman was exploding as
a huge business and so in Times Square
in 1989 for most of 89 before the movie
came out which was June 23rd 1989 they
had the bat symbol you know from the
movie poster hanging up in [ __ ] Times
Square people were getting it shaved
into their heads
t-shirts everywhere it was a like
cultural phenomenon massive they did a
piece on E
Entertainment Tonight where they went to
a comic book store in Los Angeles to
talk about how well this movie was
selling and your dad bill Leibovitz was
on the piece and he was being quoted as
like a comic book store Batman expert
and [ __ ] like that and everything he
said checked out as a fan and [ __ ] I was
like he ain't ya lyin this guy's [ __ ]
right but I remember like being so bold
like I saw that I recorded it had it on
a VHS would watch it like all the
[ __ ] time and [ __ ] as a comic book
fan it just thrilled me that some adult
was validating my interest in saying
this [ __ ] is selling like crazy and
this guy had the store that looked
amazing we had decent comic book stores
in New Jersey this store looked like
[ __ ] Mecca and I always said like one
day I got a [ __ ] go there years later
you know when clerks brings me out west
finally 90s in 94 I'm doing press and
[ __ ] like that one of the first things I
do is say can you take me to Golden
Apple comics and they're like on Melrose
and I was like isn't that a TV show it's
also a place and I was like that was the
name of the TV show so they took me to
Golden Apple and I walked through the
door and it's big you got to remember
the original location which was on like
right off of Fairfax a block or two and
from Fairfax right across from the high
school was [ __ ] massive not only did
they have comics but they had [ __ ]
toys and then all the sculptures and the
model making and [ __ ] like that
it was big it was everything you dreamed
about walking into a comic book store
and saying and I'd been to one in
Manhattan of course and stuff and this
rivaled that but is this was a little
more special because I'd seen this
[ __ ] on TV on that video so many
times so I walk in same [ __ ] guy who
was interviewed on Entertainment Tonight
bill Leibovitz his [ __ ] standing
behind the counter and I was starstruck
gobsmacked staring at that dude and he
was like can I help you I was like I saw
you on TV
and mind you this had been six years
prior that I saw him on TV and he lowers
the bulletproof glass no but he was
legit like he's like six six he was huge
looks like a mafioso guys got a usually
as a you know we had like a Hawaiian
shirt on right yes not a guy you would
think running a convict so I didn't look
like the comic-book guy from Simpsons
although most people think it was based
on him did they really Matt great shot
there's a customer for years back in the
original life is hell days and so they
thought maybe they based him on bill my
dad but not true he wouldn't copy not
1979 this is the this year's the 40th
and or da yeah 40 [ __ ] years of compo
retail and we're still doing it we had
you in I was just yeah dad you win we're
gonna have you back well he I wonder if
wink wink one of my I'll be back in a
heartbeat one of my favorite memories
like in my lifetime with my wife was at
Golden Apple man like I I interviewed
with her and met her the day before and
then like they were sending a
photographer to shoot us doing the clerk
signing with Jim my food and Gilbert
Hernandez oh yeah at Golden Apple when
it first came out and stuff and this
like it was such a special day for me
because I love Hollywood you know I was
a kid from New Jersey that's all I cared
about and [ __ ] like that like everything
about Hollywood just you know [ __ ] I
love not like let's do coke off
someone's ass not that part of Hollywood
[ __ ] but like you know [ __ ] they put
stars on the ground stars are just
falling out of the sky and they're all
over the [ __ ] sidewalks and and
people are so important they put their
hands and [ __ ] cement and [ __ ] like
that and the words written on the hill
like all of that's where they make
movies and TV and [ __ ] like that
so coming out here like was a big deal
in the first place being accepted out
here was completely different I made a
very East Coast decidedly East Coast
almost [ __ ] you were
coasts kind of movie but it was embraced
out here ran at that the Laemmle sunset
5 for 51 weeks almost one year straight
like gives that midnight shows and stuff
but it just kept [ __ ] going
but one of the biggest like oh my god
I'm we've arrived moments was that
clerks signing the clerks comic it was a
line down Melrose over a thousand
[ __ ] people man like to the power you
man all for you well and also Jim my
food and Gilbert and Anna's those guys
but but bill like you know I'd known
bill for years after at that point
coming into the store and shopping and
spending enough money to be noticed and
[ __ ] I would always tell you bill you're
the one that saw me on TV once and still
talks about it you but after that day
bill was like Jesus I had no idea people
liked you big moment so my wife came to
that signing for just a minute to drop
in because the photographer from us met
her like the David day before she
interviewed them so she was by a magical
place it's a very magic place whoever
wife there I do yeah who else got met
Megan Eastman met his first wife Julie
strain at Golden Apple
who else Seth Green Seth Green met his
wife Pablos in over there
meant for you Pablo many people there's
some famous people and some sort of
famous people there's a guy named Pablo
Pablo 40 [ __ ] years man your dad like
laid the track for a lot of us that we
put our trains on including a train that
you still run on the tracks man what is
it try my best because you do a great
job he wore size 16 eleven and a half
over here no I'm doing my best
you absolutely fill the dudes [ __ ]
shoes man like honestly if my kid took
over my leg well your kid came in and
did a Harley came in and didn't Lee it
was graves
see I'm really growing up she's amazing
she is that's a chick that's comfortable
around a comic Tarantino movie that's
amazing I know that was kind of Swift I
got lucky this year finally out a kid
that's paying off and [ __ ] right oh my
god took like 20 years but like it's a
slot machine I could put money into it
now it's like oh [ __ ] bring me another
cup
now I've even we started publishing a
few what is the book where is that
behind you I donated some with some
golden apple gift certificates in it you
know this is what we'll be giving out
tonight when we do the Q&A part so what
is the book called well that books
called adventure van okay and that is
done by actor Michael Macmillan he was
in True Blood and he's in crazy
ex-girlfriend and he created and wrote
that are by Ryan Cody it's an original
graphic novel right there and this is
and what else was the other then the
other one is called blasts of sorts
which we're gonna just gonna give
everybody on their way out we can give
you a copy of Blastoise or I'll [ __ ]
I give it up for my man
that one's cool because like one of the
main characters how much like Stanley
it's kind of an homage
it's just burnout kind of you know
stoner uncle named uncle Mars and you
know I just I thought you dig it I gave
you a copy of it I have one ago I think
your fans would dig it I think this is
right up your alley
sweet sweet the I should point out too
like this is there's a tradition in
Golden Apple of publishing books that
goes back to your dad for years on the
sign at the original Melrose location
what was the characters thing flaxen
flaxen that's right and he put out his
own book also some books that caption
what was the other one
two books by published Co published by
Dark Horse and the craziest thing about
that for you comic book you know serious
diehards out there like you coy over
there it's actually it's actually
written and drawn by Brian Michael
Bendis are you [ __ ] even Mac what flaxen
was that's legit right there are you
kidding well the top writers and comics
wrote frickin flaxen now put that in
your pipe and smoke in Kevin's that's
that's and that's like years before he
even did like fortune and glory and [ __ ]
like that no serious before he did all
those goldfish and fire yeah that's
before jinx even that's before David
just written he said you know he drew
way before you was you know mister the
writer that's right yeah holy [ __ ] what
a piece of tributes to that book yeah
what does that book go for then
our work is early work or whatever Wow
alright so when we do the QA we're going
to be giving these out thing and it
comes with sir gift certificates how
else are you celebrating the anniversary
fortieth year what we've been doing some
anniversary signings with some big-name
people and we're gonna kind of culminate
it with a big party at the end of the
year where everybody's invited everybody
here everybody in the whole world
invited we're just gonna be a party I'm
I think that's that's just the style we
are we're a family business and my mom
still works at the shop couple days a
week are you [ __ ] me really
absolutely Sharon my mom is I'm gonna
say it on air she's seven eight sorry
mom I like did she like looked around in
case she was gonna shoot she's a golden
apple working the front register a
couple days a week she's amazing and
it's the heart and soul of what we do
you know we're a family business we take
care of our people and we sell comic
books and have some fun so you got to
remember Los Angeles is a place where
they make a lot of entertainment where a
lot of pop culture is born and people
need to feed on something in order to
create pop culture and stuff like that
and for 40 [ __ ] years Golden Apple
has been feeding the imaginations of the
people that feed everyone else's
imagination give it up for Ryan and
Golden Ass
[Applause]
thank you for being here are you read a
lot of comic book so we appreciate that
I'm the same subject
beautiful work on the same subject while
I was in I was at Golden Apple because I
was doing a piece with Collider with
Khoikhoi come on up here man
join us real quick give it up for coy
how's it going folks watching at home or
some folks here in the room will
recognize coy from the feature he does
all the time and awesome from Collider
but what is the feature you're doing
where you go to comic book stores so
it's comic book shopping and it's trying
to bring awareness to comic books you
may see a lot of movies but people
forget that they're there books - you're
doing the Lord's work that's the thing
like coy in this piece we were supposed
to go to a comic book store and I was
gonna tell him like this is what I'm
buying but I was like I haven't bought a
comic book for years man like I've
stopped reading when all of a sudden the
new 52 happened and they replaced my
universe with like a new thing and I was
at god bless I'm out and so when I read
books I generally generally read classic
stuff Khoi currently [ __ ] reads
comics that's a unicorn and like
everybody knows the movies
nobody really [ __ ] studies the
current comics so we did a piece where
we went through the store and we're
sitting there kind of collecting [ __ ]
and whatnot and totally and we he got to
break down a bunch of books that I
wasn't aware of at all and in the piece
they bought me a pile of books which was
very sweet yeah I want people to know
that that Batman is also available out
of the theater and I I think there's a
lost art to actually going every
Wednesday and like picking up and like
smelling the newsprint and Walt Flanagan
man you got to bring back the world of
like buying everyone in long boxes and
bags and boards and Silver Age bags and
boards give them room to breathe but I
think it's really cool that like these
movies are making a million dollars and
you can discover all new worlds as like
Admissions like everything you're
experiencing is just right there so I
got that I got to show you the new
Batman vs Superman and Tom King stuff
that's it hit them to some titles that
they should be reading anyone watching
at home or in the room who's like oh I
you know I like this [ __ ] but I'm
actually I'm not actually reading comics
give them five things that they could
pick up that I'll actually bring them
back into the comic book store hundred
books a week five no pressure uh saga
changed my life
I think saga is amongst the craziest
books to exist period do a brief do
brief breakdown of it for those watching
what is talked about a saga it's only 54
issues halfway it's on hiatus it's fine
that is a phone book collect the Old
Testament so it's a book that basically
features a Romeo and Juliet asks story
but it's about different races and the
book teaches you not just the world you
live in but other worlds and you meet so
many characters so quickly you're jarred
by how quickly you love them and it's
about tolerance and intolerance and war
and peace and love and kindness and the
thing I like most about it is it's the
most human book that doesn't feature a
single human being in it so it's a book
that's just it's about horns and wings
and there are these rival factions on
moons we've never invented and it's a
book that just keeps you guessing and at
no point do you not feel a swelling of
emotion whether it's protagonist or
antagonist and I haven't felt that it's
like the Golden Age of Kirby it's just
so inventive and insane but it feels I
keep describing it as Looney Tunes means
this is us it's like the scope of that
madness meets oh my god Milo why so it's
just it's everything so so saga if
you've never read a comic decider and
are Brian cave on and then the artist is
Fiona staples and they're both just
racking up eisenerz as they should be
and they're on hiatus right now so
you've got time to read 54 issues in a
day and then jump in so yeah Fiona
staples is just the line work is
beautiful and if you've never got a
comic you don't need to have touched it
so it's it's amazing that's number one
number one mr. miracle mr. miracle is
Tom King is an ex-cia operative which I
tweeted it so it's safe to say I was
really worried about that and
planet as a creator Tom King is a writer
on Batman he's a writer on mr. miracle
but in a former life he worked for the
CIA
so we effectively like writes Batman
like a guy that works to the CIA because
he knows so I love that his Batman is
just this gritty he's experienced things
but he's not tied to canon Tom King just
plays and his Batman is so different and
he made Bane cool again like his opening
is about Bane and and Bane is the
equivalent of Batman in so many ways
they're they're two sides of a similar
coin people play with Joker all the time
with the control and sanity but Bane as
Batman if he was born in a different
place in a different way Tom King brings
that and then he has the Joker fighting
the Riddler in the next arc and what do
you did with Batman's crazy there at
issue 79 so you're not too far behind
trying to think of the approachable
books the ones that aren't intimidating
so Batman I mean sorry mr. miracle is by
Tom King who's writing Batman but mr.
miracle is a book about scot-free whose
power is to escape anything and as an
escape artist he wants to kill himself
so he's trying to escape life so it is a
book that is light and fluffy an escape
artist that can't escape his own life
why does he want to kill himself he's
just had so much he's just seen to my
look he just can't quite deal for those
that don't know the characters is one of
Jack Kirby's new gods characters and and
mr. miracle eventually wants is he with
MS with in this so he and big Barda have
a childlike halfway through his on
spoiler about halfway through and
there's a nine page panel of child birth
that made me openly cry at the Oaks I
was just like sitting at coffee crying
like oh no it did this so it's amazing
it just finds emotions and the comedy is
so unique and it's Mitch Gerard's on art
who draws just staggering everyone feels
like someone you've already met and
they're all wearing like DC Comics merch
which is great you get this little
flavor of like good New Gods wearing a
Superman shirt just feels right mr.
miracles book - what's another super
approachable let's just give it a three
then just do class one friendly
neighborhood spider-man friendly
neighborhood spider-man is going that
Tom Taylor who's this Australian writer
and ex circus guy which I just found out
and the book is so contained and so
friendly that you meet his
neighbors and you like encounter what I
like Peter Parker's life is through Tom
Taylor's very specific humor and flavor
Juan Kabbalah's on art it's
photo-realistic with wacky hijinx and
the most recent issue which I got you is
like a Mary Jane issue in the current
MCU there's a giant troll fight and Mary
Jane tux Peter into bed because he's
worked all night and goes out in five
trolls it's amazing
so the comic we're like Golden Age of
comics right now friendly neighborhood
spider-man mr. miracle Saga like
everything you can pick up its glorious
right now
fuckin'-a man the important part of all
this is remembering comic books and COI
remembers boy where can they watch you
we're not they see you so I'm going to
show every week in Collider it's all
Collider heroes it drops today is a new
one at 5 o'clock so every week at 5 and
then your episode of comic book shopping
drops in two weeks and I try to bring
people into comic book stores to show
them like hey this is where it comes
from so it's it's the best job in the
world did one with Jake Gyllenhaal
right yeah went to London with Jake
Gyllenhaal so me and Jake went and
talked Mysterio and then Dovid actually
I do t be such a good scott-free it
wasn't subtle I was like by the way
here's this mr. miracle book [ __ ]
nice loosely doing the Lord's work
inside purdue's but I've got to thank
you you accidentally wrote my life in 95
man like Mallrats is what happened like
I'm a comic book junkie that became a
talk show host so no no you're a lot
more personable than Brody I stand by it
that's awesome give it up a core
everybody appreciate all right third and
final guys the evening is the big
[ __ ] ticket of the evening this is
huge for us my lord does our house more
honor than I'm afraid this house can
bear by being here tonight I don't know
that we've ever had a Academy Award
winner no let alone a seven-time Academy
Award
we're gonna talk to somebody who has won
seven Academy Awards man with a list is
that the list all right we were on a
list now not even don't do the awards
with it movies like slide to the bottom
we did this in the alley before we came
out here and I was like I just want to
refresh cuz there's this stuff I know
but I was like let me just look from the
[ __ ] bottom alright and it's your
entire [ __ ] childhood who has been
imagined by tonight's special guest man
if you ever sat there well let's start
right here the scum and villainy Cantina
is based will not speak its based on
anyone not at all inspired by not even
inspired by jelly evocative has a
passing resemblance a Suisun a sprinkle
to a sequence in the motion picture star
wars and an in in the bar scene in Star
Wars you had a number of otherworldly
creatures some of those were created by
tonight's guest if you ever saw you know
David Norton become the American
Werewolf in London tonight God did that
if you were child the 80s who grew up yo
when you first got [ __ ] cable TV like
when we first got store Cable where I
lived they would not stop showing
altered states so I know that movie in
and out he did the special effects in
altered states man
the howling a movie that I like watched
today over and over her death and I
didn't even know this was part of the
repertoire the incredible shrinking
woman one of my favorite [ __ ] movies
of all time he invented sexual chocolate
yes chocolate he has believed he has
turned in Eddie Murphy into more people
teach him playing in movies then is
humanly impossible chamalla beautiful
God God made from only one face for
Eddie Murphy this guy let Eddie Murphy
be all of the [ __ ] clumps in the in
the Nutty Professor
he won Oscars let's do the Oscars list
all right I mean he's done gorillas in
the mist
[ __ ] dude and then this is before you
get into [ __ ] like like to face in
Batman Forever working with the folk
Peter Jackson in the frighteners I
forgot the I always invoke this movie
all the time especially now with Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Gus Van Sant's psycho
remake shot-for-shot worked on that he
made or Eddie Murphy old in life he won
an Oscar for making Jim Carrey the
[ __ ] Grinch ladies a job
[Applause]
men and black tropic thunder a movie
which cannot exist today yeah you you
could not hey you couldn't no you
couldn't and Robert Downey jr. does not
get nominated for playing blackface
today yes I'm surprised he got for
playing blackface Dan he awkward he just
true but true
Maleficent man those [ __ ] the horn
heads and Maleficent
did that he's the architect of
everything that ever made you happy in a
cinema even on TV I believe on that list
Beauty and the Beast from the old Butte
in these series of mounds and the beast
was is as well that I before I got into
film as like I want a direct and [ __ ]
when I was a kid what I dreamed about
was a special effects makeup doing that
like I had blood and nose putty and
[ __ ] I would make fake knives and
stick him in my friends and [ __ ] like
that and lay around our parents houses
and wait for them to find us and she'll
like that
but didn't have enough talent to pull
through because this special effects
makeup requires artistry and you have to
be able to sculpt and you have to be an
artist in your own right graphic arts
and visual arts had never been in my bag
which is weird to say cuz I'm a
filmmaker but you know what I'm saying
this man on the other hand had a
brilliant mind and brilliant hands to
match and has created some of the most
indelible [ __ ] characters in pop
culture history he's got a book that
we're gonna talk about and to say it's a
book as yeah [ __ ] try picking it up
mark hold on
stretch stir it it looks like a
two-hander you take one side Jesus even
as a two-hander it's thick as a dick man
let's turn it around the the definitive
deluxe 2 volume box set of our guests
makeup and visual effects work man and
even when you look there at the box it's
just like Jesus this all looks like a
haunted happy childhood give it up for
the goddamn legend man Rick Baker late
[Applause]
hey hey hey I got a corrected before he
started I worked on altered states but
it was a dick Smith movie I just did
some work on it so fair enough before we
go generous you are cuz you could have
been like it was me but you're like who
were your heroes because you're so many
people's heroes a hero in this business
who want to do what you've done and did
what you did who who did you look up to
well I think my first was Jack Pierce
who did the Frankenstein's monster and
the Wolfman and all the great classics
of Universal makeup buddies there
Lon Chaney I mean his makeups were still
some of the best makeups ever did he do
his own he did his own but there was a
guy named Cecil Holland who was around
at the same time who I think worked with
them you know when you're when you're an
actor and you've got it you know this
kind of makeups had constant touch up in
he I'm sure he couldn't do that because
he was concentrating his acting you know
but but his stuff is brilliant so where
was it what did you see that made you go
hey that's the world for me well you
know I was the first generation of kids
to grow up in front of a TV you know and
it inspired me you know you know every
weekend all across the United States
there was the shock theater package
where there was always a horror movie
host and they would show the same movies
and and I loved that stuff and you know
Wizard of Oz was an event movie that
would come on and I loved the makeups
and the characters and I found by
accident I was like you know a latchkey
kid my both my parents worked and and
I'd come home from school by myself and
let myself in you know when my mom came
home from work she'd take me to the
supermarket because we didn't have
childcare and I went one day and there
was a famous Monsters of Filmland issue
number three in the in the magazine rack
and what is this you know and it was
like well I gotta gotta buy this 30
worst Ackerman J Ackerman your sacrum
and this is in the very beginnings in my
my mom's did you say it was issue three
issue number three yeah I'm
let's stop my heart oh my gosh he's old
yeah and that's why I'm sitting down but
you know my mom didn't have the 35 cents
to spare and I went when they could
afford it I get a quarter week allowance
so I started saving my money and it was
just a fluke that that was there and
every time she went to the story I'd go
with her
finally when issue six came out it was
there and I had my 35 cents so I bought
that and in Famous Monsters had talked
it was like a film magazine about
monster movies in fantasy noir and
science fiction and but it was a film
magazine had talked about the people
behind the scenes that people who
directed it as well as the actors and it
showed me that it was people do this for
a living and I thought you know I want
to do that you know this so I mean I
started making masks I start doing
makeup when I was 10 I made my first
mask on his 13 how did you know how to
make a mass we're self-taught I mean I I
was self-taught but I was fortunate had
my father was very creative and in his
lifetime it was discouraged you know it
was like he grew up in New York you know
do something you can make a living at
you can't make a living drawing and
write like that
because of that he encouraged it into me
you know I had the best parents in the
world they were very positive thinking
and when I told them I used to say I
used to I wanted to be a doctor I mean I
told this story many times I thought you
didn't do it but I wanted to be dr.
Frankenstein you know I really you know
and in my little you serious so used to
watch the movies instead of like I want
to do makeup you're like I want to sew
dead things you know I wanted to have
the laboratory with these Kenneth strick
veterinary equipment and stuff you know
and I do now actually have I have a full
scale one in a miniature one that I
built two but you know I just thought
when I went to my mother and said you
know how I always talk about wanting to
be a doctor yes Ricky were so proud you
know I was like well I kind of changed
my mind you know and when I told her I
wanted to make monsters for a living she
didn't hit me you know she said she
could have in those days for less yeah
dreaming smack
you know she said you could do anything
that you set your mind to and you want
you know if you really work hard where
did you grow up with the support group
in Covina which is east of years so in
California Southern California I was
born in New York but my parents moved
here when I was like one you know and
Covina is like 30 miles or 40 miles east
of here
it wasn't like film there were no film
people there it's not like living around
here right right and my parents weren't
in the film industry and when I first
met some people and the very first guy I
met was a guy named Bob burns I don't if
you know bob is he's a collector but he
was he played a guerrilla and in some TV
movies and things and and I he took me
under his wing he taught me some things
and introduced me to some makeup people
and took me to the Union when I was 15
with a box full of stuff and I thought
they were gonna give me a job you know
and and the business rep of the Union
said he told me to give up that I was
never gonna get in and that the kind of
make ups that I wanted to do which were
the monsters and all that stuff he goes
those jobs are few and far between and
most the time you're just going to be
mopping sweat off of some [ __ ] actress
and it was like well that's not what I
wanted to hear you know but that's not
as encouraging his mom and dad and all
not at all you know I mean I thought for
sure he was gonna give me a job you know
but in the reality it was at that time
it was all nepotism you had to be born
into the industry I didn't know anybody
I wasn't born into it you know but it
probably made me that much more
determined it's like you know what [ __ ]
you I'm gonna show you that was 65
that was like 1965 versus young yeah it
was like probably 65 or 66 yeah so what
was the what was the the big change I
guess in the industry at that time like
I think what planet e Apes is about to
come out and that sort of the resurgence
of science fiction as a marketable thing
yeah it's it's fortunately you know I
mean I used to think kind of wish my
parents had me sooner so I could have
worked on all the AIP movies and I could
have been the Paul Blaisdell of AIP you
know and thank God they you know they I
came along when I did you know I had the
right skill set at the right time
you know in the 70s when I started doing
low-budget independent films because
that's all I could do because I wasn't
in the Union you know and they told me I
was told by the president the Union when
I did King Kong the Dino De Laurentiis
King Kong where he played King Kong in
that movie wait let's not roll over that
did you just say you played King Kong
and that relate King Kong in a movie
[Applause]
I've learned to accept that a lot of
people that were kids at that time liked
that movie you know I personally was a
big fan of the original King Kong and I
thought it was a travesty that they were
making another one right and you know
John Landis was that guy oh my god you
were the internet before the internet
wait I mean John Landis said you know
some Italian guys gonna remake King Kong
if you believe that and I said you know
they're gonna get some idiot and put him
in a gorilla suit and I was right you
know
so wait did they now that movie weren't
didn't they try to build like a giant
working monkey or no well yeah it was
all the publicity was about a 40-foot
robot that is in six shots in the movie
and they did build the robot they did
build it it was only done at the very
end of the production and the funny
thing was they wanted to keep me a
secret I understand you know I mean it
sounds a lot more impressive there's a
40-foot robot in this little Joker in a
gorilla suit so they weren't out there
promoting the fact that like King Kong
is played by a guy no no no no and the
only reason I got any any publicity at
all is say there was a day you know I
put the suit on in the morning when I
put my hard contact lenses on in the
morning I wore the suit all damn day you
know took it off at lunch came back so
I'm sitting there in front of an e fan
which is like a you know fan that
doesn't make a lot of noise about losing
and the director John Kellerman comes up
to me goes today a Thai magazines coming
you're gonna do an article about King
Kong but we don't want him to know that
you're playing King Kong so if the guy
talks to you don't say anything gonna go
I got a [ __ ] gorilla suit on what am
I going to tell him you know
so they made the mistake they showed him
like 20 minutes of footage all me you
know and they go now we're going to take
you and show you the big King Kong which
wasn't finished so they took him over
and showed them this is our robot you
know he goes well where's the finished
one I want to see the finished one
that's in the movie that I just saw yeah
they went they said well actually it's
just this guy
you know got some publicity which now
for you if you you love the original
King Kong the original King Kong was a
stop-motion miracle so if you in a world
where you're like I can't believe they
were remaking this it's not even
stop-motion it literally is you in a
suit mostly that Joker in a gorilla suit
in front of a blue screen you know and
yeah and this was in the photochemical
compositing days where blue screen had
to be so flatly lit really you knows
during the summer I've got a suit made
out of bear hide and rubber and the
whole crew is in shorts and tank tops
you know company about how hot they are
and I would literally pour out I could
fill up a Styrofoam cup with sweat from
my feet at the end of the day oh when I
took the hard contact lenses out you're
supposed to worry for ten minutes and I
wear them all day you know I couldn't
see and I had to drive home down the 405
in the foggy eight the makeup or no I
did I did it with you know the funny
thing was they contacted me originally I
went in and I thought this is because
you know my fascination with monsters
I liked fooling people with makeup as
well and I went through a blood and guts
beard you talked about doing that you
know I to the point where nobody in my
neighborhood would play with me anymore
parents wouldn't let him and you know as
it was as in my bedroom I was an only
child very shy and stay to my bedroom
made masks you know made monsters and
built my Aurora model kids you know and
read my Famous Monsters were you an
Aurora kid I yeah I mean I for those
that don't but probably a lot of cats
you hear the smattering applause those
of us remember from childhood maybe cats
don't know now if they're older they had
these a wonderful Aurora model kit
snapped together model kits and they
would do like triptych spread like
yes seelix you know Frankenstein the
Wolfman Dracula and stuff like that you
must have parents that love you if they
bought you those my parents wouldn't buy
you no I mean my parents you know I grew
up very lower middle class I mean my mom
was a bank teller and a lot of times my
dad didn't have a job you know you had
went different jobs and then he
eventually tried to make a living as an
artist which was very difficult yeah but
I remember vividly the day I'm in my
bedroom working on something and my dad
knocks on the door who opens the door
with the Frankenstein model kit you know
it was a dollar and it was his dish no
and it was like it's cool James Bond my
artwork on it and I know that you went
without lunch so that I could get this
model kid you know and i mean i i'd so
lucked up out in the parent department
and and in just in life you know i mean
i've had so many people have been so
nice and you know i made a living out of
my hobby and I got Awards for it and
free food and [ __ ] you know and you know
it's interesting the book you know or
when I read it I I didn't write it
who put it together Jonathan I always
say his last name wrong what's his last
name in there Rinzler Jonathan yeah
Jonathan interviewed me a bunch and I
also had if I didn't have copies of
inner articles that were done on me my
parents had him which I inherited at the
end he did all this research and it's
really interesting the way you put the
story together in my life and at first I
mean I'm a visual person I don't read
well I don't can't do math you know I
wanted to be all pictures you know but
there are a lot of good stories that go
with it
yeah they're hard to get out of these
two volumes turn the whole thing
I don't want to break my finger yeah
there you go
oh my god look at how gorgeous they were
yeah he like has a guy who bought Famous
Monsters of Filmland like this is what
happened to that boy like he bought that
that magazine and look at [ __ ]
everything you've done
Jesus Christ man you live it's really
weird looking at it looking at your life
in a book like that I really thought I
was gonna die you know I mean it was
like really good my life passing before
my eyes you know but there's stuff
there's star wars you know one of the
things you didn't mention that I did
which I'm really surprised is Michael
Jackson's Thriller and when you
mentioned he mentioned Tropic Thunder
and how can be done this in this day
when they called me up you know
originally I didn't know what the movie
was I just got a call and they go can
you do a Photoshop it with ridging of a
Sean pin can you do a Photoshop a Sean
pin make him look like a black man and
we can have tomorrow and I said can you
give me a photo of him so they gave me
like a photo out the internet which
isn't very good I found a better one I
did it did it did an illustration up and
you turn him into a black man and I went
what's this for knee goes what don't
worry about it you know and then then
the next one was like Sasha Baron Cohen
and went through a whole list and
eventually was Robert Downey jr. and I
went what is this you know and then he
sent me the script then he went are you
gonna be able to make this isn't gonna
cause a lot of trouble you know
and I was really surprised that it
didn't you know there wasn't goodbye I
was - we were just talking about it like
before we went outside we were like how
did that movie get away with that and I
guess the nearest which I could chalk it
up to us like I guess people just really
liked Iron Man a lot like where they
were like well he's a great Iron Man
will
you know and he was nominated for an
Oscar wasn't it yeah was he for that
yeah and did you win for that no no no
you nominated no I wasn't even nominated
for that I mean some in 84 you know I
mean it was like gorillas in the mist
where I did his gorilla suits that
everybody thought were real gorillas
because they were intercut with the real
animals no nominations that is are there
any real gorillas oh there's a lot a
real girl this stuff but they could only
shoot I mean when they you know I've
been a gorilla person my whole life my
fascination with monsters training and
fascination with gorillas and and I
thought they were the closest thing to a
real-life monster and the more I found
out about them you know they're very
passive animals you know and I followed
Dian Fossey scurry roar as well as Jane
Goodall and and when she was killed
I thought someone's gonna make a movie
and I'm gonna I'm gonna get a call I got
a call from Warner Brothers and from
Universal like on the same day basically
and they said we're doing a movie about
Dian Fossey and we want you to do Drella
suits for me oh yeah great but they said
we want to shoot the real animals and
then we're gonna in make scenes out of
whatever we get by you know the stuff
with your suit and I said I can do this
I think better than anybody but I can't
make a suit that you on film will be you
know real gorilla fake gorilla real
gorilla all right so do it all fake or
do it all real it's not gonna work you
know they said well this is what we're
gonna do and it people didn't know you
know but we would it was amazing Stuart
Baird who was the film editor that took
all the footage he would we were 11,000
feet up in the mountains in in Kenya and
the Aberdare mountains sleeping in a
tent Lions would walk through camp every
night you know you'd hear him they'd
wake you up and but he had a like an
editing room and he would cut together
this footage and go I've got this
gorilla going to here and I've got this
gorilla you know same girl are going
from here to here but I need this shot
so we'd go out find a place we'd shoot
that shot they put it in I mean it
worked you know it's crazy
are you kidding I mean there are the
suits I always wanted to build the King
Kong experience I mean I wanted to I was
like 25 you know and I thought this was
going to be my only opportunity I mean
how many movies do they make about
gorillas you know and to make a
realistic gorilla and they didn't want
it they wanted a Hollywood ape you know
a biped originally they wanted to be a
caveman when I went in there they said
well it's during the time of disaster
movies you know towering
yeah urban Allen big Irwin Allen Johnny
Gill ermine who directed intercounty and
Pharrell they hired to direct it they go
it's a disaster movie you know the
original King Kong was crap you know
it's like I almost left there and and
our King Kong it's gonna be more like a
caveman you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about a King Kong if anything it
should be a gorilla on steroids not him
you know I gave man man my get mighty
Joe Young or something yeah you know so
I mean they actually and I said you know
I'm about to start in another movie was
a movie called squirm I don't have
anybody seen squirm yeah
or worms burrow into a person's face I'm
about to start this other movie but if
you want me to do King Kong I can pass
on that and we'll get back to you they
didn't get back I started a squirm and
they go we want you and I go I've taken
this other job you know I said I can
finish it really quickly and then I can
I can have somebody else put the stuff
on I'll come over when in the meantime
when I came over they they said well now
we hire Dena brought one of his friends
from Italy Carlo Rambaldi who said he
could build a 40-foot robot they can do
the whole movie so we don't really know
if we need you he's a genius I go he's a
liar you know NASA can't build a robot
man Cizek and wanted but we all wanted
it to be so true that's why it was easy
to believe it like of course you're
gonna build a 40-foot giant King Kong
and he's gonna be my best friend when do
you ever see it work well no because I
mean what what did work really well were
the hands where I thought were great
right and it was in the blood
let's shot with Jessica laughs yeah
we're
and actually that's one of the few times
is actually on the stage with Jessica at
the same time because everything was
blue screen you're on behind well I'm
always looking at a hand that isn't
there and she's always looking at a big
ape that isn't there yeah that's right
because you plan a scene where the hands
like undress or I was actually on a
platform and they were shooting over my
shoulder with the big hands down there
with a split diopter lens so it could
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me so they have
a giant robot hand touching her and
they're shooting over you in the
foreground yeah and and it was like oh
my god you know that nobody will
probably ever do that again
right in the age of CG they're just like
will draw the whole thing yeah well you
know it's it and maybe rightly so in
some in some instances I mean you can do
things with CG that we can't do I mean
people always try to pit the CG guys and
rubber guys I appreciate both
technologies and I think it's great to
have another they work together I had
hoped that there would be a lot more of
a marriage between the two not so much a
war between the two right it's very
tribal isn't it what a man I like rubber
hey man I like digital but it requires a
filmmaker who has affection for both
right I require something like JJ or
Peter Jackson to say you know what I
remember and I love this stuff as a kid
let's do it that way exactly and I think
that's I think that's one reason I was
successful in a lot of people I know
Dennis Muren who's somebody I met as a
kid who is the visual effects guy in
Star Wars and Ken Ralston and Phil
Tippett and all these guys I met my very
first job was at a place called Chloe
productions they made Gumby and Davies
yes you worked for fat [ __ ] Chloe
Chloe at that point they didn't go aiya
this well right most of the work I did
was on Dave and Goliath and are you
worked on Davey and Goliath
with my entire morality and I was raised
Catholic but I got nothing from that
organization everything I learned was
from those [ __ ] that boy and his dog
and sometimes his sister yeah Davey God
is everywhere Davey you always I heard
that voice all day long forward and
backwards you know but that place it was
that you know his stop-motion you know
there were I was a Harryhausen fan you
know place you know I was a magnet to
anybody that was in into stop-motion so
I met these kids like-minded kids you
know we're all the kind of misfit geeks
in school you know and now we all have a
bunch of Academy Awards you know that's
mind-bending just just take one more
minute to appreciate Chloe productions
you know they had they were doing Gumby
and pokey was the horse's name right
which was very popular and then what the
church of jesus christ and latter-day
saints were like here's a bunch of money
make some propaganda for us so kids will
behave and a completely [ __ ] work it
did and it's funny because you know they
would start with us Lutheran's things
yes but the symbol of the Luther Church
and there was a guy there who worked on
Gumby as well as Dave and Goliath named
peak Lionel be kleiner was a pedal steel
guitar player named his name was sneaky
pete he played with the beatles he
played with it almost everybody he was
30 years old a time I was there and he
was like I I was like 17 and it was like
it's cool that you could be 30 years old
to be a cool guy you know cuz he's we
used to have these clay fights we'd get
old gum bees and roll them up and throw
them at each other and but it's like on
the stage where we're filming
stop-motion you know and it's a frame at
a time and it's you if we would hit one
of the puppets it would destroy the you
know the the ladies at work but Chloe at
that time wasn't there he had taken a
bunch of LSD decided decided that he was
going to run for president and in the
Free Press
there were full-page ads saying vote for
Gumby's father for president you know
and so the company was run by Ruth Chloe
his ex-wife who didn't care about the
business really you know same place to
work you know summer job
I remember the opening logo was the logo
of the Church of Jesus Christ latter-day
saints insanely religious which didn't I
didn't bump into because I was a
Catholic kid and [ __ ] but other people
who I grew up with be like you watched
that weird Jesus show and I'm like why
is it weird and it wasn't until I grew
up I was like I guess that is kind of
weird but they would start with the
symbol and then it would like morph
essentially using Kleist stop-motion
clay into the main characters of Davey
Goliath you [ __ ] worked on this here
tonight the very first thing I did was
sculpt Davey's mother's body and I did
it a little too realistically you know
and I when I brought it to the guy that
was in charge he went no no no I started
pushing it all around you know she
doesn't need a sphincter you know the
funny thing was cos Pete who also wrote
the Gumby song I don't know if you ever
saw Gumby where there's a song in the
beginning Sneaky Pete wrote that song he
wrote that Gumby saw that Gumby was once
a little rain wall of a slab slab of
clam that slab of clay yeah but he would
do stuff like there was a one of Davey's
teachers was black got a black female
and he do shots and at the end of the
day they had time he would like you know
pan the camera over and have Davey's
father making out with a black teacher
progressive yeah you know and doing
stuff like that and that's how we had
fun you know American Werewolf in London
game-changing movie game-changing
special effects
a horror movie that influenced any
horror movie I ever tried to do because
it was our movie that filled you with
dread while also poking the dread
balloon with a pin and letting the hot
air out and making you laugh and then
refilling it with dread it was a
wonderful balance but the special
effects are what made the movie and what
everybody of course remembers and you
got her you got to recall that at the
time
a werewolf transformation was more along
the lines of a lon chaney affair a
series of dissolve shots of you know or
a guy turning away and cut to the other
person going well I've been cut back to
a guy in full makeup and [ __ ] so when
they get to the era of howling and and
and American werewolf and where are they
in related relation to one which one was
I mean I I did John Landis is first
Salish Locke when I was 20
John had already written the script he
wrote it when he was like 18 or
something and he goes my next movie is
going to be this where with movie nice
like describing the whole movie to me in
great detail and John is very animated
as you probably know and I'm trying to
make him up and it's like you know this
is great but you got to sit still I
cannae know but he's gonna be my next
film and I want you guys I want to do to
me a transformation if your body's going
through this change this metamorphosis
name on my book you wouldn't sit in a
chair you know I want to show the pain I
want to I want to be able to have the
guy move around you know how would you
do that I have no [ __ ] idea but I'd
love to try you know cut to 10 years
later it didn't you know John's your
schluck did animal heard of that yeah
once he did Animal House season he
became a little more legitimate you know
and then got the money but I got a call
before John called me about America well
if I got a call from Joe Dante and Mike
Finnell who did the howling and they
said we were doing this werewolf a movie
would you be interested and I thought
you know I had 10 years to think of how
to do this transformation it was really
wanted to show off so anyone yeah
so I told him all about what I wanted to
do you know and as the way things work
like I said like you know the girl isn't
a mess two movies the same time
like I think it was a week even later I
get a call from John good news we're
gonna make it work American Werewolf and
I went oh [ __ ] John you know I kind of
taken another movie because you [ __ ]
hearings like yelling at me like John
does all the time you know and there he
comes now and still mad yeah I still mad
he is don't matter you know but I said
what I'll do I had a young assistant
Protege who came to me as 13 year old
who had never done makeup and wanted to
learn his name is Rob butene so I taught
Rob holy [ __ ]
I taught Rob how to do this stuff and I
got and I actually recommended him to
make some piranhas for Jo's piranha
movie so they already knew him
and I said I'll talk to Rob Rob can take
over I'll do John's movie you know it's
a win-win situation you know and the
howling actually came out first because
it was made very quickly and what was
cool is I had some people that I was
going to use and there weren't a lot of
people doing this stuff at the time like
I said I trained Rob because I needed an
assistant you know I brought Steve
Johnson out from Texas another guy off
from Connecticut who sent me a fan mail
you know and and and we're interested in
this stuff and they ended up helping Rob
and can you know I so I got I consulted
on the film so it was kind of like a
trial run you know and I said to Rob I
don't want you to do this I don't want
to do this at these save media let me
have these ideas like this stretched out
body when David's body training
transforms you know they it's true now
that I think about it like when I think
about the transformations and howling
they're not painful whereas the one in
were the ones in American Werewolf are
like I'll never forget him [ __ ]
screaming as his hand
[ __ ] stretches while he twists his
fingers whereas in the howling the
transformation shots are more like a
hand down here with some fingernails
coming out with a camera like panning up
to give you the idea of like some sizes
yeah yeah and it was you know it was
shot like a horror movie with horror
movie lighting yeah America
was shot you know John says it's not a
horror movie in that this I wanted to
look like a real apartment lit like a
real apartment and it's like that's
gonna make it a lot harder John yes you
can do things we actually had a plan you
know we did we storyboard of the whole
thing and I would say you know this
because David Naughton has in like no
hair on him you know it's like he it got
progressively hairier so I said let's
start with him Harry
I could trim the hair and pull hair off
faster than laying here on taking that
off laying hair on again so you know the
movie came in under budget you know we
filmed in Piccadilly Circus a bus crash
we had like I think two hours to go in
their film this bus crash clean up the
mess and get out you know and I at the
time I didn't appreciate how well
organized it was just just to give folks
like you know for lay people who are
like wow that doesn't sound hard if you
were gonna go do that today it would
take two hours just to load everybody in
[ __ ] put up the chairs and bring the
monitor in and stuff like that I boots
point they'd be like alright you're done
get the [ __ ] out you know what was great
about that though - in in you mentioned
Star Wars and this looks very much like
a set that I've been on but I guess we
can't say there but not actionable
that's what we liked is that yeah so
many times you know the kind of stuff I
do the directors would always leave it
to the last shot of the day because they
don't want to deal with it you know and
you know to me it's kind of like the
money shot through these kind of movies
you know yeah it's like okay we got 10
minutes you know let's do this effect
now and I go come on you know like said
you know how about if we do it in post
you know in Owen casual you know they'll
never work you know but we did an
American World you know I and then I
said Star Wars you see Star Wars yeah
you know the cantina band
yeah they were never in England they
were never in the same room with
Harrison Ford or anybody we shot it here
in LA with a different crew did you know
that there's no I [ __ ] know that
you're ruining my childhood and Wow
really that was done later it can happen
you can do it your movies or a series of
cuts you know and you think because the
music is playing you think the band's
there you know grito agreed or whatever
his name wasn't you know I never knew
the names these guys we actually it was
that was stuart freeborn did the stuff
originally he did Chewbacca
it was his film he did the original
cantina scene the wide scenes are all
Stuart stuff George wanted to embellish
on it at the time nobody knew Star Wars
was gonna be Star Wars you know and as
far as Fox was concerned they had
already spent too much money on this
movie that they thought was never going
to go anywhere so there was like no
money in no time and he wanted to add to
the scene and because my friends were
doing the visual effects he went to him
and said do you know anybody that can
make a mask and they said yes you know
and so they called me over to what it
was you know and valjean avenue where
they were shooting out used to became an
industrial light magic before it moved
up north showed me on a flatbed editor
that scene as it was and it was like oh
[ __ ] this is great you know I can't
worry you know this be so cool I want to
do you know I wanted all this stuff I
went and he goes I don't have any money
you know in a Yugo so you really have no
money go I'll do it anyways you know a
number of the aliens did he remember
things I made before there's like a
devil guy yeah yeah that was a mask I
made four years before at least more
maybe more so you just through it and
you're like I got a bunch of stuff
stupid werewolf that they show in there
that eventually cut out which was
horrified I was like a a mass production
mask I've tried doing you know I thought
it was gonna be stuck in the background
there's a big close-up I was like but I
mean the rest of us as children were
like yeah and you're like [ __ ] man
buddy I mean I wanted to do more but
there wasn't there wasn't time for money
and at the same time I was doing a film
called the incredible mountain man which
actually was paying me a lot more money
you know so and on the day we filmed
everything on in one day and on that day
I had a big day in the melting man I
couldn't be there so I had to send my
crew to do the Star Wars stuff you know
and it's like you could work on Star
Wars and been there that you are doing
the incredible melting man the [ __ ]
wrong with you and that's when your
career went in the toilet what what did
you get more pleasure out of doing was
it the stuff that's designed to look
invisible like the gorillas like that
that the audience doesn't know that it's
in effect or the [ __ ] that is just like
blood coming out of his eye his head is
flipping back and that's clearly clearly
makeup monster design or get me look at
me stuff or the [ __ ] that like wow I had
no idea well you know I think like or
Davey and Goliath
that's [ __ ] huge
sculpting Davey's mom's boobs with
silicone you know were the best things
they did my own boobs
nobody's it's funny I like both you know
I like it when people go what makeup you
know I did Martin Landau is bale of the
go see the bloody guts stuff is the
easiest stuff to do you you can do a
really bad appliance you have really bad
edges you put blood on any people go
like this anyways you know the human
stuff is the hardest stuff like the
Nutty Professor I really enjoy doing
that because first of all was very
difficult but it was also like a real
showcase because he was so many
characters and you could you saw him
without makeup as well you know and they
were gonna cut that scene out the
families the dinner scene what yeah they
they were in it they were gonna cut it
out because they would have no sequel I
know yeah because you know they said
well I said Eddie can only be one
character today because of the makeup
time the removal time you can't do two
characters a day so him playing five
people in the scene if who would
normally take one day would take five
days so some accountant right well let's
just get five
we'll be done and we'll save four days
work you know and it was like you guys
don't understand you know and I called
up Eddie and I said they don't
understand we have to show them and I
had already gotten the first casting of
the mother character out of them out of
the mold said come over let me make you
up shoot some stuff we'll send it to him
so I made him up as the mother and Eddie
said you know I don't know how I'm gonna
play this yet I don't know what I'm
gonna do and I did like I did on coming
to America kept him in the makeup chair
in front of the mirror let him play with
it so a videotape to him and I just
started to ask him questions you know I
know it doesn't take much to get any
started you know go you know just tell
me about your son Sherman need to start
going and we discovered what the mother
was going to be he went through ten or
so different characters it was very
clear the mother who was before she was
like she did that in the video that I
shot you do other things too because it
was like Universal was gonna cut cut
this stuff out so you know he would keep
talking to mr. Universal in the video
and at one point his like we had water
balloons in his breasts in and one of
them burst you know and he goes mr.
Bursch do you know but a couple days
later at 8 minutes as the grandmother
and he knew exactly how he's gonna play
that it was moms Mabley you know and and
you know I cut this stuff together and I
said you watch this [ __ ] and tell me
that you want to cut this out of your
movie you know and they cut to when they
see me this script for the Klumps eddie
was everybody in the movie you know it
was like that scene was so great we're
gonna have Eddie play everybody you know
what you can't make this movie it's
gonna take ten years you know I would
love to see it and I would love to do it
but you can't do that you know and it's
like Hawaii is it the same reason you
wanted to cut it out in the first movie
it's time-consuming yeah like put it all
together and it's a brilliant piece of
the classic comedy I mean one of the
things that I I care so much about my
work and I'm a pretty even-tempered
quiet kind of guy but if they're [ __ ]
with me and they're making what I think
is a mistake I'll fight for what is
right it's not popular in Hollywood you
know everybody goes yes of course you
know I go no you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
rinche they went to Jim Carrey painted
green that's all just green on Jim
Carrey as going no you can't do this you
know so I mean I I did a makeup test on
myself to show what I thought it should
be and they said no no that's too much
you know and I did something that to
convince them that I actually contacted
there was at the time this internet an
equal news thing yeah Estella's yeah
Harry was a fan and I called him up and
I said listen I need some help
Universal wants to paint Jim Carrey
green I did this really cool makeup that
it should be can you say that you saw
this test in the universal guys idiots
nobody goes sure you know so you guys I
make her do this test really cool makeup
this is what the Grinch should be they
want to pay Jim curry green what the
[ __ ] wrong with these guys you know
and this was at the very last minute and
they didn't know that I did this you
know and Ron called me and go somehow
this guy in Texas got hold of your chest
footage because they sent a copy to rob
and and to Ron into a Brian Grazer and
goes and you know he's saying that it
should be this and it can they changed
their mind because they thousands of
people go what the [ __ ] wrong with
these guys you know so I mean the Grinch
would have been Jim Carrey painted green
stud to grant you Ryan Reynolds dead
pulled that [ __ ] long before he did man
how does your process change given the
act of who you working with like you
know David Naughton his werewolf is
different from Jack Nicholson's werewolf
like when you come into it knowing full
well it's gonna be Jack Nicholson how do
how do you cope with the fact that you
can't cover that much of your movie star
well I mean I everything's done before
the script you know I mean the script is
what inspires me and the way I want to
go is it you know and and also what the
actor would be one thing to put up with
I mean David you know was the Dr Pepper
guy you know which we're going really
you know you know I'm over
oh my god for those who don't [ __ ]
know those of us who grew up in the
seventies and [ __ ]
before he was the American Werewolf in
London the lead of the movie David
Naughton was the guy who did the dr.
pepper commercial I'm a pepper she's a
pepper that was it then yeah and didn't
he sing making it that was the other
place Wow and then he went on to be the
America war over London yeah but what
David I you know I told him you know and
story he he tells us like when he came
to my studio and I said what character
you're playing he goes you know David
and I said I'm sorry
it's true though I mean we did some
really hard things on him you know you
know he was buried in the set for a day
we did stretched out body you know just
the top half of his body she you know
real body sticking out you know Jack
Nicholson wasn't wouldn't do that yeah
that movie again didn't call for that it
was it it was more about him benefiting
from the werewolf thing you know in in
that part of the movie I thought was
really cool then I turned into a monster
movie it got kind of silly you know but
but Jack you know they I they first
approached me and I said I'm surprised
you're even contacting me about this
because it's not very much wearable to
stuff and it's really about Jack getting
better and it should be little lessons
more in the makeup department he goes
that's why we were contacting you
because you know that you know what I
said but I actually have another film I
can't do it I turned it down another
person is did it it was doing it and it
was like two weeks before filming and
they said he did too much and they said
can you please please help us and it
turned out the movie I was working on
got cancelled and I said yeah didn't go
but I said I want to I need to talk to
Jack about what I want to do for the
make up and it was like well nobody
talks to the great oz you know not
nobody not know how you know I go the
first day on the set isn't gonna work
for me is it to be doing this makeup and
I need to talk to him so they said okay
you can go to Jack's house it was on
Mulholland and buy them by the way at
this point you're it's not like you're a
first year and your career your [ __ ]
Rick Baker at this point like you've won
Oscars by this well you know the funny
thing is it I can't tell you how many
times I have to say to the two producers
and stuff why the [ __ ] did you hire me
you
when they go because you're the best in
the business they go then have faith
that I know what I'm doing you know it's
I mean one of the reasons I retired was
40 separate producers going you know
maybe if this poor was over here you
know and it's that stuff right it's soul
sucking you know American Werewolf John
Landis said you're the expert
I want a four-legged Hound from hell I
wanted to do a biped werewolf he said no
it's a four-legged hound from hell
you know okay I made it that way I mean
III did a couple paintings a couple of
quick sketches but my first sculpture is
the final werewolf you know the first
sculptures I did on Jack is I'm Griffin
Dunn's makeup is is the first thing I
did on the Wolfman I did thousands of
designs and it was do one in between
this one and now and do one in between
this one and it got to where there were
no in-betweens I go I can't they are so
close together just [ __ ] big one you
know and it's frustrating and his soul
sucking and my work has always been
really important to me I it's what I did
for fun you know and the fact that they
just don't you know they hire you for a
reason but they don't let you do it you
know it's frustrating you know the it
seems like lately the the most
gratifying work you get to do is every
Halloween I see you put up pics of you
and your family and you you don't go
gently into that good night
you make the rest of us who put together
like I'm the Hamburglar feel like [ __ ]
you did one year did one the whole
family Joker's and [ __ ] yeah yeah and
it's you know if I'm when I brought a
makeup kit to the delivery room so as
soon as the baby was born I started
making her up you know my daughter
Veronica works with your daughter Harley
yeah and II see Daisy she's a producer
of that show she not only is she
producing around the show she's
responsible for early being on that show
all right Veronica brought her in
all right cuz I asked one day the kid
was like I'm gonna work for DC jail as a
kind of [ __ ] did that happen and then we
found out it was ronica and I talked to
her I was like why and she was like just
seemed to make sense her name Harley
Quinn I was like you're [ __ ]
brilliant and I say that because like
thank you for giving my kid a [ __ ]
job that's like less money I have to
give my kid but more importantly and we
were talking about in the alley and the
alley before we came and Veronica was
there for my family I'm like what was
it's gonna sound incredibly first-world
but one of the worst days of my kid's
life she flew to New York to do like New
York Comic Con coverage for DC daily and
they lost her luggage and for a kid
who's never had anything bad happen to
her ever that was the worst [ __ ]
thing man and nobody was there for like
me and the wife were on the other side
of the country and all we got were these
phone calls of like you know my like
holy [ __ ] we didn't give this kid any
coping skills whatsoever we're terrible
parents thankfully Veronica was there
took her under her wing and like settled
there down took her shop and it was just
like it's gonna be fine and you know
most people would have been like would
you calm the [ __ ] down
and Veronica was very very sweet with
her man I have two wonderful daughters
in a beautiful wife who I actually met
like across the street that when
Frederick's of Hollywood was over there
in the middle of night I was a drug
dealer and she was a hooker and a film
called into the night and we have a
photograph John Landis movie into the
night yeah there's actually a photograph
in the book of the night we met right
across the street which is so weird and
which is also weird to me is I have the
star on the Walk of Fame just like a
block down there are you [ __ ] me you
got a star too again maybe I give you
the star it was like a like five or six
years ago something like that all again
because of my beautiful wife was sitting
over there who's much smarter than I am
and
all right
she worked without my knowledge for like
three years she somehow managed to keep
his secret she knew that I would ever
just say no don't do it you know and she
got letters from everybody from Steven
spielberger from New York all these
people you know and I got a star in the
Walk of Fame how weird is that and
that's serving bro like that's not weird
that's like you deserve to be out there
think about how much imagination you
pumped into this town
how much yourself you gave to this town
and how much of is a part at this point
of movie history like that's [ __ ]
crazy will you reference bill Berg what
was the Spielberg connection Harry and
the Hendersons well I did a number of
films the I Harry and I did gremlins to
the new batch we made a million gremlins
as a picture in the book all these
gremlins that we made on the gremlins
and imago eyes and stuff and in my
typical way and made a job much more
difficult Chris weightless who did the
original film was a good friend you know
he had one gremlin sculpt one Mogwai
sculpt you know they added a fur thing
on the you know so you only had to make
you know one of this kind of puppet and
why this kind of puppet you know they
could be any gremlin I said I turned the
movie down numerous times they go what
could we do to make you want to do this
and I said I would like making
individual characters I would like to
make individual characters of them not
have all the same sculpture and I said
let's paint it because I knew Joe was a
Looney Tunes fan you know my brothers
let's kind of base it on so you know
like there could be a George and Laney
because there was always that big dog at
little dog
doing the kind of Lon Chaney jr. lynnie
you know voice and and ago you know we
could have a Daffy one and we could have
this you know and then then we came up
with the idea of the genetics lab where
we did a vegetable gremlin and a bat
gremlin there's a Kenan peel sketch I
don't have you've seen it about
it was very much like that I gotta say
cuz I mean Joe's real open to ideas and
and I'm always one to like tell him what
I think of it you know men and black you
know the guy the lookout is in the face
that came out of my shop that wasn't in
the script you know I if I'm working in
a movie and I'm working really hard no
one it's not to be cool you know so I
give them more advice than they want you
did madam all the men blacks and I
didn't do men and black international
I'm happy to say Ric shader but you did
you did the original centenario I know
thanks Raphael
Vincent is amazing a great person in
fact he's interviewing me at New York
Comic Con and they're gonna reckon to
think about the Falls right on but you
know actors will complain you know like
Jim Carrey was ballistic about how
horrible it was to all the [ __ ] that we
put him through you know and how ever
tortured he was the one who should have
been was Vincent because I mean I had
worked with Vincent on Ed Wood he played
Orson Welles and he wanted to wear
makeup
oh that's right and I said you know I
don't think you need it you look enough
like it but we actually made appliances
but we ended up we need him not using
them you know but but I said you know
can you I started thinking about what I
wanted to do when makeup wise and it
goes back to a lot of lon chaney stuff
you know I go I really want to pull your
eyes it down like this and I want to
glue silk on your face and stretch it
around and glue to the other side you
know but you know I said can you come
out and talk to me because I didn't want
to get in love with this idea not when
you're talking about actors not when you
know what how you have to adjust the
makeup and I told him he goes yeah that
sounds great and go okay let me just
glue your eye down now glue as I dunno
goes can you pull it down farther and
it's like you know I love this guy you
know I mean it was his makeup on the
average was six hours and then you had
to film all day and it's like an hour
removal time
you know and the funny thing is a barry
sonnenfeld who directed the first three
movies likes to do table reads in
Vincent doesn't like that stuff he's the
kind of a no-bullshit actor you know he
went to the table reads and you just
read it you know he just read the lines
and then Barry says we got to recast
what are you talking about and goes
Vincent I mean he's not you know it's a
table read henkle you can't recast I'm
too invested in this guy Ball Z let's be
pull as always I'm knocked down he's got
to be great you know so I yeah I said
please please please you know so anyways
we didn't know how he was gonna play
that until the very first day I made him
up you know run location out wherever we
were and he does Edgar for the first
time and I with a big smile on your face
turn around look at Barry and I went and
I mean he was so great never complained
the scene in them in the morgue where
the little who he opens up the face his
he was made of a bunch of different
materials he was silicone gel foam
rubber his nose was gelatin and gelatin
melts at a certain temperature and I'm
watching the monitor what's going on
with Vincent's nose and I walk up and
it's like melting off his face and put
my hand in his head he hit it 104 fever
you didn't tell anybody
no just kept on working you know but I
had to replace the nose you know so his
fever was melting as my cousin fever
melted his nose yeah Jesus who was the
most surprisingly amenable actor to the
amount of [ __ ] that you had to do them
was the one you know it's funny I mean
doing what I do you know you kind of
looked at like you're the dentist or
something you know when they associate
me with pain and long hours and things
long time in the chair but you know what
I mean Vincent was great you know
somebody who I thought was really cool
too was Anthony Hopkins who I work with
Wolfman and you know she's Sir Anthony
Hopkins and again he's not a no-bullshit
actor I mean you know when he came to my
shop I said I'm not quite sure what to
call you
mr. Hopkins and he should I call you Sir
Anthony or where he goes Tony I'm Tony
you know Tony would eat lunch with the
crew you know he wouldn't be in his
trailer with you know her he would just
eat lunch with the crew he was just
down-to-earth sweet guy and the funny
thing to happen with Tony the original
director in the Wolfman wanted Tony to
grow beard because it's appropriate for
the period of time period but the I said
if he has a beard it's the
transformations gonna be that much less
cuz this is the Wolfman it's not
American Werewolf he's not going from a
naked man to before they can help her
male he's going from a guy with a beard
and maybe with a little more hair on it
it's not gonna you know it won't be as
cool I've talked to Tony about he goes
well you know I understand but the
director wants it so he had a beard
anyways the very end of shooting we're
doing his Wolf Man stuff we're all set
up to do this makeup utilizing his beard
he knocks on the door opened the door
clean-shaven maybe the big smile on his
face
look what I did for you it was like okay
can you come back in like five minutes
you know and it's like he shaved off his
beard you know now we had to come out it
like blend a bunch Errol faster lay on
him you know but he was a really sweet
guy really sweet and he never ate your
[ __ ] liver with fava beans and a nice
Chianti as well what a storied [ __ ]
career and it's contained in two vines
this book where can folks get this you
know look online if you just go AV type
in Rick Baker book it'll show up Abrams
is the publisher you can go to Abraham's
side and they show you a bunch of
different options there's a bunch of
different places where you can buy it
you know it's 50 years of photos that
I've saved you know my wife gives me a
hard time about oh stuff I say if you
know and it's like see ya you know let's
talk about that I heard a rumor that you
have all the gak at your house like all
the [ __ ] that you've built if you go to
your place it's like holy [ __ ] there's
that holy [ __ ] there's not all of it
just because I mean in my studio when I
retired it was a 60,000 square foot
studio holy [ __ ]
filled with stuff you know my display
room was probably four times the size of
this bar and I had you know two big
mightyjoyoung is a big edgar bug bunch
of stuff that i don't have root you
can't put that stuff in your house you
know i got rid of a lot of stuff but i
have a lot of stuff still because i have
a house that's my studio now I'm retired
and I having the best time I'm in love
again with with the creativity of what I
do you know and if people always say on
my Instagram I don't think you guys
follow me you should at the Rick Baker I
always post cool stuff what is it what's
the dress at the Rick Baker but there
was a year ago I had to use D but people
who say you know you're the busiest
retired guy you know you know you and I
said I retired from the [ __ ] up film
industry which I shouldn't say because
it's been really great to me you know
I've been so lucky but I haven't retired
from being a creative person this is
what I do for fun I'm having the best
time I've had in my life in a long time
and I'm gonna do this as long as I can
until my body gives out you know you
[ __ ] deserve to kick back and make
[ __ ] that you want to make without
somebody going over your shoulder like
one more whisker I think the the kid who
[ __ ] finally found 35 cents enough to
buy that Famous Monsters of Filmland
magazine change the world man I can't
thank you enough on behalf of everybody
who's loved movies for this
[Applause]
Wow so [ __ ] this is why we do [ __ ] like
this man that was just so [ __ ] worth
it
everything it was gold you see I mean I
didn't even know that David and Davey
and Goliath [ __ ] like the King Kong
stuff is what blew me away man
but I mean and I remember I remember
talking about it one of the most recent
9/11 sort of anniversaries that is what
I think of when I think of the Trade
Center I think of King Kong standing
astride those two towers it's true and
like in that movie like in the original
of course he climbed the Empire State
Building but in the 70s
yeah they threw him up on the Trade
Center buildings and so that movie is so
intertwined with my memories of New York
and my memories of childhood and to know
that he's the [ __ ] that was mind
amazing all right man [ __ ] there's a lot
of chitchat now we've got some born a
snooze to do man Mark used to be a
newsman and so he dug up some news give
it up for Mark he's got the news I do I
think we're gonna we're gonna speed news
today we can I'm gonna get totally speed
news speed because what's more important
than the [ __ ] we just heard Jesus you
walk out of here [ __ ] educated about
film history tonight man like that was
amazing just hearing like the howling
story like I I was there for a minute
and then I went over there and [ __ ]
we got this kid Rob poutine like oh my
can then go off to do [ __ ] everything
that Rick didn't amazing a lot of good
stories about selling the [ __ ] book
Rick
we know by the damn book it's amazing
all right you know how we all said a
very teary farewell to Tony stank in a
in Avengers end game it is not the last
time we are going to see Tony stank on
screen how he is going to have a cameo
in Black Widow oh my god I even thought
about that but that's positive because
if she's in the movie and she's dead
then he could be in the movie and he's
dead too first off spoilers yeah I'm
sorry
if you missed the highest right they
could [ __ ] do that they should be
like it should be like the end of Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang remember where he's like
oh he came back and then Lincoln walks
in as well they should bring everybody
who died back in that for a little cameo
and [ __ ] but I psycho sign that that's a
good idea there's not been enough Robert
Downey jr. as Tony Stark in my life I
need more you can always have a little
bit more
I just watched spider-man far from home
this morning it's available on home
video or whatever [ __ ] so I got a little
bit of taste there and stuff and once
again like I hate to be this guy but re
watching that movie like that spider-man
is perfect I really hope these [ __ ]
like figure their [ __ ] out last I heard
was like Sony said hey we'll offer you
30% of the box office to Disney and
we're still waiting to hear back but
like not being able like that far from
home is predicated on I miss Tony so
much if the next movie is like Tony who
wears Uncle Ben like it's gonna be a
real [ __ ] letdown I feel like but
they still get to keep all those kids
right like all the people in this world
are the same they just can't reference
the Marvel Universe correct it's gonna
be a bummer I really hope they figure
that out anyway Tony being a Tony Stark
bin and he's gonna be in Black Widow
which drops May 1st 20 20 and when did
they announce this and why how come we
weren't surprised by that sort of thing
I don't know the Internet
fair enough checks up in other Marvel
news Hailee Steinfeld will placate
bishop in Hawkeye I think this is a
great idea man
she was wonderful and what's that movie
I love be more specific True Grit thank
you
fantastic and True Grit she's wonderful
and everything she was great wasn't she
the voice of spider-gwen as well she was
and she was the lead in bumblebee that
was yeah she was really [ __ ] good and
that bumblebee move I shocked at how
much I liked that bumblebee movie
because I never liked to transform a
movie but that one I was like oh my god
I want to marry this one well yeah
because you looked at the trail like oh
that's just [ __ ] Iron Giant but for
real thank you yeah for real
very true robot I get it did I talk
about on this show yeah
did you see bright burn no we did talk
about it I haven't did I talk about it
yes as I said I loved it you did done
Seabright burn I just keep saying it I
keep singing in my iTunes lineup and I
can't remember whether I talked about it
it was [ __ ] dope all right next story
next new story
hey so everybody has a streaming app
right NBC just announced theirs with a
name that feels odd really I kind of
thought this was cute tell them what it
is
peacock remember the old George Carlin I
had been thinking about the Carlin jokes
not my joke but it's George Carlin
saying he goes what do you call a female
peacock a peak hunt George's joke not
mine alright so they're calling it
peacock yeah I'm ok with this I thought
honestly that Warner Brothers should
have called their app not HBO Mac's but
bugs because that's like their corporate
you know again guy like Bugs Bunny and
[ __ ] like you know when you think of
Warner Brothers that's what I think
about but they went with HBO max yeah it
seems confusing it's the first idea
theater of like what should we call it
it's more than HBO HBO mags good job Bob
yeah and they all like went home
thinking that they won something
yeah peacock it feels like like they
just didn't go through the schoolyard
taunts of like peacock white guys just
don't do this to yourselves yeah
but they are rebooting a bunch of [ __ ]
they announced a bunch of things at
along with announcing their app they
have announced a few shows they're gonna
do some of which are very surprising we
live in the age of of the reboot and the
recoil and the sequel and the remake and
stuff and it sounds like they're digging
deep into their coffers to [ __ ] with our
nostalgia is that correct pretty much in
case you wanted to know where punky
brewster is today you're gonna find out
is it gonna be so almond it's still a
moon fry as grown-up punky brewster
because sure you know I support that I'm
all for it somewhere somebody's like
desperate to see that show
and I may not be that person but I'm
glad it exists and [ __ ] are they
bringing back the dog Brandon well has
he passed on Marc let let me get back to
you on that that wasn't part of my
initial research who else what else is
it well shame by the Bell
is coming back this is interesting
because it's Saved by the Bell
but it's a it's not a reboot it's no
it's just a sequel the same way that
punky brewster is what's she doing now
now it's like Oh mark-paul Gosselaar is
the mayor the governor of California
well not mark-paul Gosselaar
yeah governor Zac that makes more sense
[Laughter]
and then the other thing there they're
bringing back is Battlestar Galactica oh
really
yes they are they are not remaking the
Glenn Larson show nor they remaking the
Ron Moore Show it is some entirely new
it's not a sequel to either of those
it's not a sequel to either of those Sam
s Mel who did homecoming and mr. robot
is executive waiting it
what do you mean homecoming oh the show
yes not spider-man yeah I was like what
sure how did I not know he did yeah he's
mr. robot guy yes mr. robot guy is sort
of overseeing this thing apparently he
had a meeting with Ron Moore which went
well and that Ron Moore didn't like kick
him out of the house but so yeah they're
making Battlestar again and nobody knows
exactly what it is nobody knows exactly
how it will mirror what we've seen
before how it will diverge from what
we've seen before but but nothing
nothing good can rest it will have
Cylons that's all it needs right it will
probably humans on the run from Cylons
they will probably it'll have to be I
mean it's an exodus story at its core
it's and genocide feels like it's also a
part of it it was even part of the 77
show like oh no humanity's been
destroyed we're on the run that which is
super grim dark for 1977 but alright I
mean I mean look they've been trying to
do for a while remember a few years ago
they Brian was threatening to do one as
well so it looks like this one's
happening and having it with is a really
nice Batman to Kevin Smith from one
Batman fan to another Taylor meet close
where's Taylor where are you
well done man's a good looking [ __ ]
Batman man oh is that the one of me I
took home the circle picture yeah that
was the one I did for you and this is
[ __ ] Clint Eastwood as Batman yeah
it's
one my favorite like from The Killing
Joke when he's sitting down with Joker
so to speak are you sure it's not what
he says to the chair and the Republican
National Convention hello
I came to talk I've been thinking lately
about you and me what's gonna happen us
in the end we're just gonna kill each
other Harley perhaps you'll come me
perhaps I'll kill you
perhaps sooner perhaps there let's Clint
to a chair I totally did it I'm gonna
sit in you you could crumble very nice
well done all right well I got Margo
Roby whoo that's right I said it right
right yes my walkie nixing that she is
our cinematic Harley Quinn amongst
others indeed she is also potentially
going to be a cinematic Tank Girl oh
[ __ ] really yeah they're gonna do it
again they're gonna do it again she's
producing a remake reboot whatever of
Tank Girl potentially for her to star in
[ __ ] hey that's but smart somebody
doesn't like that idea at all in the
back somebody feels away about the
Rachel Talalay did the other one the one
that with Lori petti in it and stuff and
she was doing comic book movies at a
time when nobody else was doing comic
book movie she's since gone on to direct
two episodes of the flash and Supergirl
and a lot of Doctor Who stuff Doctor Who
as well she's wonderful but she was the
shot that movies good I still stand by
Tara no not you you have nothing I stand
by it until the iced tea as a kangaroo
and I kind of make like a hard left fair
enough what other news we got here is
something that is very specifically
distinctly a rumor and I'm going to mark
it as such fair enough
Marvel in deciding the direction they're
going to go with their mutants which I
don't think they're calling x-men
anymore and I think there
is called the mutants marvel in the
comics or marvel cinema Marvel Cinematic
Universe okay
the rumor is that they are considering
casting Professor Xavier and Magneto as
people of color right on I think I mean
look I don't I mean number one I was
never a person that would give a [ __ ] if
they did that but number two I'm like
we've seen almost twenty years of the
other two and then also the other two
who played the other two
let's why not like especially in the in
the new Marvel Cinematic Universe in a
world where the like we have to do
something different like do that and I
think that they're they're sort of
thinking if it's true might be the
analogy between Professor X and Magneto
has always been characterized as Martin
Luther King and Malcolm X right it was
like we both want the same thing but we
were going about it in fastly different
ways one of us was we have a dream the
other by any means necessary right and
so maybe taking that sort of metaphor to
its perhaps
illogical conclusion they're going to
potentially cast African American actors
or African British actors I don't know
it'll probably be somebody British it's
like a [ __ ] Alba like you made
yourself can you imagine
Idris Elba as magneto and [ __ ] Denzel
Washington as Charles Xavier
that guy can
that's a that's a good pick casting call
where did you hear this rumor where did
you read it let me see
full circle cinema that's sounds I first
word I [ __ ] said this is a rumor I go
with that that makes me I'm interested
I'm not like oh man they're ruining it
I'm like oh great there have a plan good
I can't wait and to be clear like in the
comics as we have come to know them Erik
Lehnsherr is a Holocaust survivor oh
yeah for years and movies as well right
but was not always Chris Claremont added
that in x-men 150 in like 1981
is that right yeah so prior to that
right it was just a white guy who like
had some [ __ ] about metal but yeah
Claremont was like well I was looking to
find a way like what was the defining
event of the 20th century and I wanted
him to be like sort of victim of it so
the Holocaust was his answer to that and
so that was just introduced into the
Canon and became canon but was never
always the way which just goes to show
that these are living stories and they
can change and evolve and they can shift
and they can expand to include lots of
stuff when I was talking to COI for the
comic shop bit he introduced me to a new
x-men Court you still here was the x-men
comic House of X and powers of 10 what
are they doing
hold on they're rebooting the entire
universe communicating for those of them
rebooting the entire universe as we know
for a while Fox had more of the x-men
come back to the spot yeah you can
handle this find your light coy so they
you know there for a while in Marvel
Comics because Marvel Studios didn't
have the x-men the X they stopped making
x-men comics and they stopped making
Fantastic Four comics now that Disney
owns all the toys again they're
reintroducing their characters into the
universe in a big bad way what are they
doing with Marvel's and with the x-men
mu
there's two giant event books that are
six issues each and they all turn eight
week to week so house of X and then
powers of ten but what's fascinating is
House of X deals with mutants we know
pretty well but powers of ten plays with
the concept of time so it's ten years a
hundred years and a thousand years in
the future so the power of ten we all
thought it was powers of X until the
book came out it was like oh they're
messing with time as the x-men are want
to do and the most recent issues have
done a lot of giant continuity defining
things that make me think that when they
finish this run there's six new titles
and I'm not sure we're gonna recognize
any of the characters as the x-men we've
had for the last 50 plus years like
they're they're handling continuity
really aggressively the books have
charts and graphs and like there's a lot
of schematics who's the writer you were
saying like this guy actually Jonathan
Hickman redefined the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four already and now he's
doing x-men and he made more McTaggart a
mutant Maura is now a mutant that
relives all of her lives up here but
dies and then can tell everyone the
lives she's lived so in issues she's
basically an extremist mutant that is
like hey magneto this crazy thing
happened and then she dies and then she
comes back and she's like hey Xavier all
this crazy thing happened and then she
dies and then she's like let's try this
and she apparently has a limited number
of lives and where it ends off she's
down to her last one so we're
experiencing tons of continuity and then
there's also another book that's like
here's the x-men and your brain it's
like watching five shows at once like
I've never felt dumber and smarter at
once
maybe thank you very for what they're
doing with mutants in the Cinematic
Universe I heard that was the rumor but
it'd be really aggressive because the
reason we're infested is because we love
more McTaggart and like Xavier and all
those things they were like trust us
you'll like them and then you're just
went in gallivant event I don't feel
like I don't think that's the way to
soft reboot I'd do it like you know play
with time and set it in the past and
actually use your Fantastic Four and
x-men with period pieces instead of just
like hoping we believe in you but
they're both great books I just think
it's gonna reboot the comics so they can
sell more toys when the movies come out
there they're clean slated I just I
don't and there's also like too much
Wolverine to really make that work cuz
we just lost Hugh I don't think they'd
go like by the way the activin are just
Wolverine again and the
other guys so I think the books are
gonna be separate [ __ ] hey man give
it up for koi let's go here on the
ground the last two items are from the
questionable decisions file okay
paramount has decided they want to
remake face-off
I mean I don't know why you would I
would you know I could cease equalizing
it if they were like hey let's do it
again with the same guys I'm not like
I'm all for saying Nic Cage and John
Travolta overact but I don't know that
it's a concept that necessarily like I'm
like oh I couldn't wait till they read
it why am i speaking into this oh I
couldn't wait until they [ __ ] redid
that it's so much like a bong you just
wanted what is what is this whose is
this others are playing that in here so
am i signing this side or am i signing
the mat inside the mat inside thank God
I asked I was about to saw and sign the
container and you would have been like
what an [ __ ] I mean my problem with
remaking face off is that it's the only
reason we like face off is because of
the execution of face off yes
it's because of those guys that map to
resident John with John Woo and as Daffy
as that [ __ ] movie is he made it work
he made it work and just like that
concept in and of itself does not scream
like oh this is gonna be great it's
after you do it I just want to make sure
am i doing it on the mat anywhere does
it matter it's for Matt the Matt it's
for Magic the Gathering so it's a Matt
that one plays the game on it stuff the
Magic Man and it's got a very cool
picture of the mage in the sky with a
[ __ ] it looks like a scepter of some
sort could I write on it yo I'm stupid
no I'm just kidding
I'm sign right above this guy's [ __ ]
head and I'm pointing an arrow to say
that is me I'm now claiming this
character back to you sir back to you so
yeah paramount is gonna do that sure
whatever
Omar can sign it to go like hand X I
took the best spots are yeah what else
is new that was Rick Baker level shade
right there
in the second of the questionable
decisions column Sony has decided or at
least announced that they are
considering rebooting remaking Reese um
thinking a Princess Bride once again if
they were like hey we're gonna sequel
eyes it because you know William Goldman
left a secret script behind that nobody
ever saw and Rob Reiner wants to direct
and all the characters who've played the
characters want to come back
I would totally support how to cup and
Wesley you're still alive so you can
totally do that absolutely but if you
tell me that like now is just say movie
different cast I'm like yeah yeah why
would you do that that movies [ __ ]
perfection hello my name is Inigo
Montoya you killed my father prepare to
die stop saying that oh I [ __ ] love
that movie suffer me money offer me
everything in the world I want you son
of a [ __ ] Oh such a good [ __ ] move
and that's not even like the best part
of the movie no but it is so emotionally
gratifying and [ __ ] life is pain that's
before you get to like no more rhyming I
mean it does anybody want a peanut
I hope you rest well and dream of large
women
inconceivable that's all I have in the
news yeah I hope they don't touch that
man but then again you know look [ __ ]
one day we're gonna be sold we can't
stop it there's no such it hopefully the
asteroid is hurdling yeah and Waverly
but you know it's nice to [ __ ] hear
is like here we are is 2019 and we're
like oh man they shouldn't [ __ ]
remake that Rick Baker just told us a
story about from the 1975-76 and he's
like man why they remaking King come
nothing has [ __ ] changed you know
it's always been a series of people who
are disappointed in Hollywood over and
over again that's all the news mark
found the news give it up for marketing
now on this best of all possible and
very long shows ladies gentlemen we now
come to the part of the evening where we
do the QA and that's the part where we
engage you folks the audience and give
out some prizes for you guys answer ask
asking questions that we get to answer
we got some fun sponsors as per always
the good folks at 40 X screen X our good
friend Deacon has hooked us up with
three beautiful gift bags inside of
which of course there are how many movie
- oh you got a separate image show oh we
have three empty bags could you imagine
if I was like here thanks for the bag
jerk bringing things there's gonna be
three bags and in those bags are gonna
be two tickets apiece
to go check out a screen X or 40 X movie
or is this a screen next movie
those are either or both either or both
a great way to see a movie we took
everybody to go see far from home in a
screen X experience where it's around
you and [ __ ] and then I've been to 40 X
so as Mark many times I've talked about
the experience many times I saw somebody
on Twitter this week
hey like after you talking about 40 X I
finally went to a [ __ ] screening he's
like you're right it made me [ __ ] so
there it is I can't think of a better
area to have a condition yes
it's a chair that shakes you up so much
you can't help but burst with joy and
other fluids so go see something at 40x
what would be the movie to go see right
now in 40x
Downton Abbey go see Downton Abbey in
4dx as they spray water your face
because the chair moves shaking yes the
smell of hot tea and concern
it's still it yeah there you go see it
and they said that it's a great
experience watching it in 40 X or screen
X there it is man so you're gonna get
the people who ask questions tonight are
gonna get the 40 X tickets they're also
going to get as pointed out by Ryan
Leibovitz a fine copy of adventure man
which also comes with a gift certificate
to Golden Apple ladies and a sign cream
and then of course there's always our
good friend Nate Dark Knight Returns
Nate Gonzales makes this gorgeous
artwork for every one of our shows the
dream being that sooner or later he'll
print them all up and that's what we can
paper the bathroom walls with every one
of these [ __ ] things he did another
print man that looks achingly like a
movie I saw once I can't remember what
it is I had some karate in it I believe
this is its beautiful poster it looks
like a VHS cover and stuff like that
Nate is insanely talented you will get
assigned one of this posters signed by
me mark and Nate as well so the three
people that get to ask questions they're
gonna get one of these sweet-ass fat man
be on prints by Nate they're gonna get
40 X tickets and they're going to get
something just fall off the bar could
you grow this yeah they're going to get
adventure van a book and they're gonna
get a gift certificate with the
adventure band book to Golden Apple [ __ ]
this show pays out doesn't it's like a
broken slot machine man that you find in
a corner of a casino just keeps spitting
[ __ ] up we asked JC the fine proprietor
of this here Cantina to Cole through the
questions and pick the three that we
then talked to those folks to everyone
give it up for JC
and then of course JC tell us who we're
gonna be talking to first up Tom
Principate Oh Tom come on up everybody
give it up for Tom hey Tom
how are you Tom I'm done all right how
are you I think we were a little more
enthusiastic than you were we're like
hey Tom you okay what's up you to me
I've never heard that before my lighter
note what can we do you for
alright so I work at a certain theme
park in Florida and this conversation
has come up before so I'm talking about
SeaWorld aren't you once upon a time I
did yeah but I know you've done them all
you're one of them parcours you're like
I work at all from parkour yeah that's
exactly yea parkour parkour
but mainly there was a conversation that
we had that if you had to choose a non
horror genre to make a like a Halloween
Horror Nights house or Haunted maze out
of okay like when they do those [ __ ]
like hey man it's Halloween time come
yeah have you guys been to some kind of
mr. thing yeah yeah I don't talk about
it much
yeah yeah no it's fine
just yeah you got some scars looking
Reese past it man you know what I
shouldn't a corn maze Oh J so much
calling so basically you know it's
obviously it's very easy to pick from
some of the the classics but my thought
was you know what if you had to pick
from something that wasn't horror you
know and as an example what I pitched
was Doctor Who which is not harder at
all but you know but you can totally get
a doctor who maze out of it oh yeah
weeping angels you know Cybermen any
anything you know so what would what
would you guys pick and why I mean I
would of course lean into one of the
properties so it's either DC or marvel
man will you
like a world to walk around in DC I
would lean more toward because you could
pick Arkham Asylum if you did a live
Arkham Asylum like maze or something
like that where it was themed exactly to
Batman's world and whatnot so [ __ ]
like it is a scape room of sorts as well
and everything was a Batman [ __ ]
villain you don't even have to have
Batman in this [ __ ] could just
be the prisoners of Arkham Asylum I
would do that in a heartbeat but I think
what would make more money well I don't
know would make more money if you put
that out after the Joker I'm sure it do
well but like six months ago I would
have said Game of Thrones man you could
do a game of Thrones [ __ ] world maze
or something like that
stand by Arkham that'd be dope you the
warriors wow that's pretty good man so
what all of New York and all the gangs
and you got to get to [ __ ] Coney
Island at the end it's good just for the
baseball fury if you do it for the
[ __ ] baseball for you that's true but
yeah I do warriors that's a good poem
man
let's do a few more because it's so easy
you know they actually a long time ago
at Universal in Florida they did a
maximum carnage because they have the
Marvel Island yeah yeah yeah they did
that but they couldn't play with some of
the character because they're the
licensing that they have for the theme
parks is very specific to a course they
can and can't use and that I think you
guys were talking about that actually a
week or two ago and trying to figure out
how that where that was gonna happen
basically islands of adventure
Mississippi is where that everything
east of the Mississippi Universal of its
if it's a theme park thing they get to
do it even when I got Disney World when
Doctor Strange came out I was working at
Disney at the time mhm and they could
they had a little meet-and-greet kind of
thing but it wasn't actually they
couldn't bill it they couldn't put it on
a map because they couldn't say Marvel's
Doctor Strange so I'm gonna get around
it and even with some of the stuff that
they do they can mention characters like
guardians of the galaxy but with the
Marvel title I think universe
has has that unlock so it's and well I
wonder if they have a or duty they could
just do it forever or will that end
basically that's the way it seems right
now is that I mean I'm I'm no lawyer I'm
nobody who is able to say what's what's
coming or what's happening but that that
I don't think that's ever changing for a
long time could you imagine like I'm
sure Disney's like man that really
irritates us because they love to own
their toys and it seems like that's a
view that are out of touch it's like
should we just by universal now hey
sorry doing a show back to you sorry uh
maybe just Disney buys Universal yeah
that'll happen sure and it's on its way
alright wait let's do one more anymore
yeah all right I got one go the running
man oh [ __ ] that's good that's real good
just for that like weird fat russian
opera singer do dynamo that is [ __ ]
good man there's another but a like
that's a corn maze anyway I mean I this
is a little more obscure but like you
could do the raid remember that movie
the raid redemption where they go up
[ __ ] it's kind of what they did in
unit Dredd as well like you know
basically storm the tower and [ __ ] so
then you could do take a building an old
abandoned building and just go floor by
floor fun idea sorry fun idea
great question give it up for him he
want some [ __ ] ladies
come get your [ __ ] well what if you did
the there's an episode of the
Ghostbusters cartoon where the
Ghostbusters go into the containment
unit so you actually did Ghostbusters
you're a Ghostbuster and you go into the
containment unit and you see all the
ghosts Wow
it's in the what the Ghostbusters house
of universal that's therefore crib for
Halloween right now part of the concept
don't go inside any time then wowthat's
then they took it from the cartoon I was
gonna say that's that they should do the
next movie about that but Jason's doing
Jason Reitman do in the next movie
that's a little piece that wasn't in the
news Ernie Hudson announced as part of
ghostbusters 2020 and Dan Aykroyd are
now announced as parts
I thought we knew that no they just
announced Dan I think or Ernie was just
the other day
so right now that leaves one name left
Sigourney Weaver two names are left -
ladies and gentlemen Rick Moranis a
bunch more to get in there but it really
sounds like they're making a flat-out
sequel fingers crossed man teapots
that's they need her it's what the next
generation yeah they've got kids in it
and and the classics but they still
hadn't announced the classics and now
they're starting to come out so I'm
fingers crossed on I think we all just
assumed everybody was gonna show up
except for Bill Murray and that's the
big will he will he or won't he well
like I can't see Dan Aykroyd being like
I have so much else to do he's just on
Joe Rogan he was a fascinating [ __ ]
guest because he's way into like aliens
and stuff and he told the like not only
did he tell the story about UFOs he's
like let me tell you about the three
times I've seen you for the four for UFO
signings I've like I've never had one
he's had [ __ ] four and [ __ ] what do
we got an actor
beau Campbell beau is it beau did you
say beau
bow oh give it up for Bronto ladies and
gentlemen I believe it's our first bow
how are you sir I didn't think they
would click me well look at you I
thought my question was mediocre but
let's find out way to sell a bow which
character or actor from a previous
decade should make a comeback and how
like somebody that people have forgotten
about like your Volta and pulp fiction
gets Tarantino who gets Tarantino you go
first
hold on hold on
can I who Carl Weathers
yeah yeah he's back I hadn't seen it yet
you seen it I have seen it nobody's and
we know he was in the rest of
development he's been back for a minute
man all right then you go all right let
me see who's some bouquet hold on I'm
thinking well Michael Keaton's [ __ ]
back in a big bad way Richard Dreyfuss
one of my favorite actors in the world
from one of my favorite movies in the
world [ __ ] Jaws
you know Plus was also in Close
Encounters for heaven's sakes talented
[ __ ] dude he doesn't like work enough
he deserves a [ __ ] comeback make him
a Marvel guy why can't he be Oh aah -
all right got another one oh go ahead
Kevin Kline yeah I mean he works but not
as much as he does a ton of voice stuff
I think that's my choice though I don't
think people are I think he's kind of
decided to do less there's a nickname
for him Kevin decline is that right yeah
just make that I didn't just make that
up but he just turns down everything
that's adorable
but he is he is one of our greatest
[ __ ] actors and you don't see him
nearly as much as you should
given these one of our greatest [ __ ]
actors Crispin Glover it's been a
red-hot minutes and so he's an American
guy is he yeah [ __ ] me in the mouth what
do I know this is my Crispin Glover
can't get ahead because people like you
reminding us if he's still here remember
when he tried to kick Letterman my mom
what you did a karate kick Letterman in
the head yeah he's like I can do karate
and he kicked him and everyone's like
what happened who else
Christian Slater but he's had mr. roba
right my guess he's kind of back who
William Katt The Greatest American Hero
last time I saw him and high-profile was
and fanboys Jennifer Grey no one puts
Baby in a corner
man
last time I saw her one of the only
times I saw in the real world was on a
plane and she's married to Clark Gregg
is she yes okay if they're not married
there a couple yes they're married
they're together though okay so I saw
him well than I knew him a little bit
and so her of course I know who she is
but I didn't I never met her before and
stuff so they were sitting next to each
other on a plane and she was like let me
sit on the aisle and of course I saw my
moment to be like nobody puts Baby in a
corner
you know and they looked at me like bro
we got six hours of a [ __ ] flight and
you rocked the line right there not only
[ __ ] people yes I decided to take
more Jennifer Grey I'm trying to I'm
hoping I'm getting his name right Philip
Michael Thomas from from Miami Vice yes
in a world where the other guys working
is like [ __ ] everywhere yeah Don
Johnson's back in a big bad way yeah
Steve Guttenberg yeah why not the
[ __ ] goop man it's all good
Mahoney he's on ballers all right [ __ ]
you I uh I saw Steve Guttenberg one who
wait who Phoebe Cates speaking of Kevin
Kline where Kevin decline that's right
Phoebe Cates been a red hot minute I
think I think those two just kind of
opted out seemed like they were like and
[ __ ] this business not altogether
who isn't he on that one of those many
CSI shows something around these guy
he's the Crystal dolls in the audience
gone [ __ ] you I never left
what sera together do I need no help
from fat man beyond I mean [ __ ] man just
because Rick mentioned did Davey and
Goliath deserve another [ __ ] try you
know
perhaps a little less religious this
time around but they did that kind of
with moral Orel a few years ago I'm
Adult Swim [ __ ] I don't know we could do
this for a while but that was fun give
it up for him great question what's that
that was you Thank You Man okay knave
not sure that I should have done John
Schneider wasn't in a small village yeah
but it's been a minute since it's been a
minute yeah all right just we just had
Bo here old school is okay old school
all right what do we got we got our
final victim of the evening there JC
Michael Andre my god everyone give it up
for Michael he's joining us upfront oh
we got a plentiful bag of booty for you
if you ask something good enough that me
and Mark can get in on no pressure
and then at all happen is an honor guys
thank ya big fan of the Shogun listening
and watching since first podcasts and
one of my favorite things has been
watching it evolve from you know the
interview bass podcast to suddenly mark
being a regular and now it's a live
performance show so JC also mentioned
that it is the two-year anniversary
that's right today is the two-year
anniversary of fat man be on here at the
at the scum and villainy
Tina and it's also our tenth straight
sellout crowd so thank you all you guys
have sold us out ten straight shows in a
road trip you guys are great yes
so yeah just sorry nervously don't be
nervous so my go all the way here from
Hawaii to see you guys
Hawaii which Island Big Island [ __ ]
Big Island give it up as the father's
anyones travel I think the beer today
thanks guys
Tessa okay we're good JC is anti
Hawaiian so he turned your mic off right
away and the brown boy is like I [ __ ]
hate those people so in honor of the
second anniversary of the show becoming
villainy what have you learned about
podcasting and performing live from each
other along this journey and is there a
favorite story or moment that stands out
in your mind from the years of doing the
show together oh what a great question
all right let me see what have we
learned what have we learned this well
this show has been a learning curve
every other podcast I think I'm involved
in I hit the ground running with what it
was and it stayed what it was this one
as you pointed out began as a show of
like me by myself talking to people that
worked on the character and then I
enjoyed talking to mark so much that we
started doing it together in the show
shifted focus less from like let's
interview one-on-one total deep dive
interview and stuff and talk about like
pop culture in general so because of
that it's shaped into like being one of
my favorite things to do because I it
doesn't require me to talk about myself
or the [ __ ] I do a lot of the other
stuff I always feel like I'm on a hard
sell and people are listening so that
they're willing to buy or whatever the
[ __ ] but like you know at the end of the
day I'm always like in the Kevin Smith
sales business more or less fat man
Beyond isn't really about that this is
just the Kevin Smith fan business you
know it's just like this is where I get
to let my hair down and be like you know
what I [ __ ] love this this this that
guy who won a bunch of Oscars [ __ ]
blah blah blah so the show really
organically became whatever it needed to
be in each era that it was and stuff but
I
like this incarnation the best there are
some people like I wish you would go
back to like just the interviews and
stuff and we did an interview tonight
which was [ __ ] phenomenal and stuff
but I I like where the show went to and
was completely surprising I never saw it
coming
part of the thrill for me and doing it
live is I do a lot of live [ __ ] and I've
been doing live [ __ ] for like 25 years I
know how to stand up in front of a crowd
and try to be funny I don't know if it
always works but I at least know how to
be gamely put on a good show mark was
not that guy at all like Mark was not
like a when I was in high school I was
the fun you know no not at all and
watching him become like a raconteur
like Mark could always talk and stuff he
is journalists so he can interview
people we're watching him like hold his
own in front of an audience command an
audience like find the edge and also
like find places to go like grow as a
performer take chances is it's very
tough to to be funny publicly because
you can always like [ __ ] fall on your
face and say something that people don't
[ __ ] find funny and stuff I always
love every show I watched mark swing for
the fences like my lines are defined
I've been doing this [ __ ] 25 years so
you know every once in a while you add
new things but generally speaking like I
know where my lines are I know where to
go mark is still like growing as a
performer so every night like he'll
[ __ ] sometimes he'll go places where
I'm like shut the [ __ ] up you're killing
us mark you know so that's fun and and
and thrilling for me to like watch him
kind of grow as a performer this was
never like that altruistic like I'm
gonna [ __ ] teach a man to fish or
something like that it came about
because I like talking to mark and he's
[ __ ] smart and and I liked when he
goes off on tangents and tells better
stories of the movies that we're about
to see or have seen and [ __ ] like that
so it's something that grew into like a
comfy bathrobe that's what this [ __ ]
show is to me it's like when I go home
in the winter really not so much the
summer although we're in the fall so
maybe it's coming soon but like I'll
live in a [ __ ] bathrobe I get home I
take off all my snot all my [ __ ] I wear
clothes under it but
put on my bathrobe and that's where I'm
like at my comfiest I can do anything
and stuff that's what this show always
feels like to me and so watching it
develop and become that has been
enlightening and awesome
you know never I didn't expect it would
wind up [ __ ] here by any stretch of
the imagination and the things we've
gotten to do and gone to we did this in
other [ __ ] states and countries at
this point I think haven't we been
international we've been a Canada and
the UK that counts is another country is
the other one yeah we've been we've been
other places not just here and stuff and
and that's it's just two dudes talking
about [ __ ] they love you know it's not
like we go out there and we're like
here's all our ideas on how to fix it
sometimes we talk about that for fun but
generally speaking is just us Fanning
out is the one show that like oddly
enough we do it in front of people but
it's the show where I feel least like a
performer in my life and anything I do
I'm not sitting here going like oh the
[ __ ] you know we've got these people
came and then they bought tickets and I
got to make sure I put on a good show
it's it reminds me in many ways of ice
do podcasts with my wife called plus one
and if you ever listened to it that was
the show that I was most myself because
I couldn't really like be an arch
version of myself or be presentational
Kev with her around she just knew all my
[ __ ] so I had to actually be myself
this show is kind of like that as well
we try to be entertaining or at least I
try to be but I don't feel compelled to
get up here and be like I bet make all
these [ __ ] laugh and stuff like that
if laughs come along the way that
sweetens the pot but it's really more
about like let's just talk about [ __ ] we
love this show has become fundamentally
important in my life you know as we
enter periods of news cycles that aren't
so [ __ ] great to open up the
newspaper let's be honest nobody opens
the newspaper open up Google News and
read the [ __ ] news and sometimes you
can easily fall into some sort of
depression about or you know a bad
feelings about like [ __ ] what's
happening to the world and stuff this
show allows me to come here and forget
about all that and celebrate the [ __ ]
that still works in this world you know
like fuggin every once in a while I see
something online where like
we put up a poster for Jay and Silent
Bob reboots gonna have fathom event
screenings on October 15th and October
17th so you go to any multiplex you can
see the movie this is before we even
start the reboot Roadshow tour so
they're giving out a poster Sabon at one
of the the first screening october 15
and as a badass piece art came from the
bond folks men love it but I put up the
the artwork and what was the [ __ ]
thing that somebody wrote because it was
such a long intro to this that I forgot
the [ __ ] punchline of the entire
[ __ ] story
I had a pothole hold on [ __ ]
wife just don't shout random words and
[ __ ] podcaster wife I'm like where she's
here no they said [ __ ] I just had it was
a compliment hold on say something else
while I think about it freckles
jujubee's I'm just I'm just [ __ ] what
am i the Winter Soldier man is blackjack
weed [ __ ] I forgot what the compliment I
was doing killer mode [ __ ] goddamn it
what was I talking about that led me to
the 15th in the central before that like
that's what kicked me into the story
when I was like October 15 to 17 you're
not selling anything you just come here
because the world's shitty and oh thank
you well done mark mark
mark was my Harry Potter pensive and
I've just taken that memory back and
[ __ ]
the person said like this poster it was
about the Jay and Bob poster said this
poster makes me realize that even though
we live in a simulation it's the best
possible simulation like I was like that
makes me feel [ __ ] good this show
makes me feel better about life and also
puts a spring in my step it makes me go
you know what like it can be negative if
you focus on [ __ ] that's like horrible
life could be wonderful if you focus on
[ __ ] that's wonderful and I know some
people like you're just talking about
movies man the real worlds the real
world and [ __ ] Art's a big part of the
real world and has been my real world
for like 25 [ __ ] years
so getting to come here and talk about
other people's art the [ __ ] that fuels
me like I mentioned before the idea of
like [ __ ] you know Golden Apple
fueled the imaginations of people that
fueled our imaginations because this is
where people would go to buy their
[ __ ] comic books and stuff like that
I feel [ __ ] like that I believe in stuff
like that I believe you have to like get
some creativity and ingest it in order
to spit out some [ __ ] creativity you
have to get some joy and ingest it to be
able to spit out joy this show is joy to
me because I'm not thinking about my
personal agenda about like I got to get
people to go see my movies and buy my
[ __ ] all I do is kick back and go like
did you [ __ ] know that they're doing
this did you know that this is coming
did you know that I met with the Joker
like accidentally and [ __ ]
so that's I've loved watching the
podcast become what it is big comfy
bathrobe you I the thing that this show
has sort of given me is not just the
most fun that I get to have any given
week because this isn't work by any
stretch of the imagination
it's here's the conversation that we
would have after going to see a movie
for two hours in the parking lot there
just happens to be 80 of you and like
four cameras and that's all of this is
but I've I've been introduced to a part
of the world and two people in the world
that I never would have met before or
cross paths with before because you know
my life was as a journalist and sure I
have friends and sure I'd you know what
Comic Con I'd meet folks in whatever but
but his fanbase is legion and passionate
and they're from everywhere and to get
to have conversations with people who I
never would have had before about things
that they never would have spoken about
before has been instructive and
illuminating for me of because we would
joke about it at first you know the
first three years in this podcast who
used this podcast was already lonely and
I was just another voice coming out of
the box and there was no signifiers or
sort of betrayals of who I was or where
I was from I was just a guy who talked
about [ __ ] that they also like to talk
about and so then we put cameras up it
was
oh [ __ ] mark it's black I mean an
inordinate amount of that I mean it was
up but not anybody offended like you
tricked me but like people like that had
never occurred to me yes I just didn't
see that coming twist and and so the
thing that happened was you know we
started talking about things like
diversity and inclusion and
representation and all that and there's
a sliver of that audience that didn't
want to hear it but found themselves
listening to it because they we already
established a common tongue right like
we all decided and we all knew that we
were nerds and so we spoke the lingua
franca of nerds and so we at the very
least came from a similar place and so
being able to use that as a foundation
of oh [ __ ] I never thought about that
before but I like you and I liked you
before I knew that you gave a [ __ ] about
that and so now we can have a
conversation and it seems as if now
pardon the pun more than ever
now's the time when people who might not
have been on the same page at one point
can find some common ground and be able
to talk about [ __ ] and be able to learn
from each other and then I have a free
exchange of ideas because that's what
civilization ultimately is about and so
this podcast has allowed me to to just
have those conversations with people and
like learn [ __ ] about people and
hopefully they might have learned a
thing or two about me
and a part of the world that doesn't
automatically intrude into theirs and so
it's been this I mean it's been a
life-altering experience to be able to
talk to people at volume and at length
and to make him laugh every now and
again I get no greater joy than making a
funny person laugh swear to God like
it's like crack and so every week I
can't give a laugh this week I did hear
the [ __ ] laugh I fail at everything
but now it's it's and then like have
said I never imagined a million years
that this that my life would involve
being on this side of a camera and
sitting and talking to be able in front
of a mic and and to be able to find some
semblance of comfort in front of crowds
of this magnitude and not just you guys
but you guys at home and then when we go
on the road there's you know thousands
of people and film or film or in Detroit
man was a [ __ ] big show
yeah you know and so to to find some
semblance of ease in front of this many
people has informed everything that I do
you know because ultimately I'm a
storyteller and sometimes you got to
tell stories to other people in order to
give them money then give me money to
tell those stories more and so being
able to just [ __ ] sit up here and
talk is is invaluable so no I've learned
I've learned to be a better person not
gonna give it up for Mark Waid answer
and a great question you win some [ __ ]
man come get your shrimp
like that you take this you take that
goddamn pleasure man what else you gonna
do in town while you're here from white
my wife is turning 30 happy birthday
holy [ __ ] man might ride with a trip to
Disneyland but I had to tell her because
of the hey can you take off work for
this reason and then we booked the
flights and I forgot to check if there
was a show and the day we flew in was a
day too late
and so I changed the flights because I
really wanted to meet you guys
means the goddamn world your ladies
probably like what a jerk it should have
been about us give it up for our man and
happy birthday happy birthday oh I think
we might have to sing we should we got
any other birthdays in the joint
what birthday is it birthday man 2
birthdays third birth time another one
[ __ ] a man told us man let's do it
all three happy birthday everybody knows
this [ __ ] song and now it's public
domain [ __ ] you Warner Brothers 1 2 3
happy bird
to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday
[Applause]
happy birthday ladies and gentlemen we
had a good time this evening I can't
thank you enough for coming out but
there is no show without the god of my
love give it up for mr. mark bernard and
ladies gentlemen one final thought and a
plug the I just you know I've been
playing a character Silent Bob 25 years
in movies he sells people weed and [ __ ]
in real life I am now gonna start
selling people weed as well we just
announced our partnership with my
favorite weed on the planet caviar gold
and so on September 27th here in Los
Angeles down at her barium which is on
LaBrea Jason Mewes and I J and son Bob
are gonna sell you weed we're gonna be
bud tenders from 4:20 p.m. on
introducing our three new strains of
weed which are in the movie this was a
little side dream of my MA wrote the
movie I wrote this plot thing in where
the boys create three strains of weed
snoogantay OG bujji's and berserker and
so when I wrote the movie I'm like you
know we live in a world where this is
possible like this weed should and could
exist and I'd be you know really
disappointed if it didn't exist by the
time the movie came out and goddamn if
we didn't get to pull it off thanks to
the folks at caviar gold so come to the
herbarium you pick up three pre-rolls
you take pictures of me and J and stuff
like that giveaway it's gonna be a good
time and I'll sell you [ __ ] weed my
mother would be so sad to know that her
son did wind up as a [ __ ] dealer and
[ __ ] she was like Tiger I thought that
was a movie and I was like my sometimes
art imitates life so September 27 come
to her bury men and
and by some we dreams do come true they
do I mean I set my bar low that's why
it's easy to achieve my dreams and [ __ ]
y'all had a good time this evening
ladies gentlemen next week there is a
show next week
next week is the last show before you
vanish on tour ok so there it is very
important information next week ladies
and gentlemen will be the last time we
do this here until I come back from the
first leg of the Jane Samba reboot road
short tour brings me home to the
screening in Los Angeles I think on
December 12th whatever it is from that
point forward we'll probably have to
Fatman beyonds before the end of the
year and stuff and I might do a show or
two in the interim what are you calling
what do you call it when I'm not here
black man be on wave man be on may be
happening right here a couple of guest
hosts with me you know some people I
know some people I know I know for sure
we're gonna have to show Helfer in here
ah-6 yourself you might have a thought
or two I might have a thought or two and
I'm lining up some other people so yet
don't be strangers in the dark times
when Kevin does not shed his stoned
light on all of us yes we will I mean
look just because I'm gone don't mean
the bar is gone so come on down to the
scum and villainy Cantina greatest place
in the world to hang out if you're into
the kind of [ __ ] that we're all
here man but that's it that is fat we
got no more show that is fat man beyond
this week for this week ladies and
gentlemen I'm Kevin Smith I am mark
Barnard and tune in next time week we're
[ __ ] I forgot tune in next week that's
what they said
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
for the good of all Krieger night ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you